Ooh,
the Joe Rogan experience podcast is
brought to you by audible.com this episode
is at least at least once a month,
audible,
sometimes twice is the
sponsor of this podcast.
What is audible?
audible.com is a fantastic
resource for audio books.
If you go to audible.com
forward slash Joe,
that's audible.com forward slash Jew
you can try audible free for 30 days and
get a free audio book.
And one of the cool
things that audible has,
if you're a junkie,
if you're into like technology like I am,
I'm a tech junkie.
They have a thing called a whisper sync
and it works with the Amazon kindle
fire.
And what it does is it's really bad ass.
Say if you're reading books on the kindle
and a you like read a certain pegs and
you go to sleep,
you,
you cha,
you bookmark it and then
when you get in your car,
an audio version of that same
book plays really cool shit.
So,
uh,
if you do a lot of traveling,
if you're stuck commuting,
whatever,
audible.com is an awesome
resource and they're cool sponsor.
It's a,
it's an excellent company and
we've got some great books.
The one I'm a I'm listening slash
reading to them doing both is uh,
Christopher Ryans sex at dawn.
We're working on getting him here.
He's going to be in here in January.
Fascinating Dude who wrote a book
about primates and sex and very,
very interesting,
fascinating shit.
Speaking of primates and sex or
other sponsors on it.com that's,
Oh and,
and it,
what does that have to
do with primates and sex?
You're a primate and
ana.com will help your sex.
I've been using a lot of
on it products lately.
Honored satcoms going to
start selling boner pills.
I think really?
Well.
We're going to start selling some
sort of a testosterone booster now.
This is certain things that actually
work with your natural testosterone
boosting.
So
I've been trying,
I've been,
I've been testing all the ones that you
can buy at the convenience stores and my
new favorite one is like the super
sex pack or something like that.
And that comes with one magnum condom
and a pill for men and a pill for women
though I've never seen a woman pill.
So like I took it and the
the woman took it and she,
she said it worth it.
Kind of let's say,
what would that be?
That would make or have women?
Well that was an episode
of sex in the city.
It wasn't like,
uh,
they,
they was,
they were taking Viagra at the girls.
The girls were taking their,
yeah,
I think Viagara works on chicks too,
doesn't it?
They say so.
They say,
oh,
so check it out though.
It's great if it's only $7 and
you get two pills in if hadn't,
it's a crazy thing is,
is Viagara for seven bucks.
You could get Viagara you can get the
condom and you get it all the a bit,
you know,
it's the weird loopholes that
you're buying it as a six pack at a,
at a drug store.
I just use the oysters
cause that one zinc.
Oh No,
I just get a bucket of
them and stick my dick.
I don't know.
How does your Dick it
in the bucket correctly.
So fat,
it's a perfect fit.
Wow.
Imagine clock as a bucket full of oysters.
Totally get your nut off sandwich bag.
Other the latest products
and on a.com we have,
these are those Blendtec you can use to
make Kale smoothies.
We've got the hemp force protein powder,
all kinds of good shit.
These buffalo jerky bars,
we're basically just trying to
sell you the best shit available.
The Best Shit for health and fitness.
All things that Doug Stan hope
doesn't give a fuck about.
That's all we sell.
Um,
uh,
including kettle bells and battle ropes.
If you use a codename codename Rogan,
you can save 10% of any
and all supplements.
All right Brian.
Oh,
cut to the bullshit skin.
Nice quick commercial.
And today,
what was that?
Oh,
we preparing for getting
does spend the world shit.
Yeah,
I was getting out of blades.
Slinger.
Uh Oh,
there you go.
All right.
This thing isn't working.
Act like you want to sing the song.
It doesn't work during,
during her,
during her name.
What's wrong with it?
And I know
is a computer frozen?
No,
it's uh,
the sounds is not coming out.
Oh,
but we've got to fix that because,
um,
I want to play bill burrs a chuck Berry.
John Lennon.
Thanks.
One of the funniest fucking
things I've overheard.
Do we have to restart the computer?
Know
why this is.
We have a,
a new setup.
That's why there's two,
two monkeys behind the boards now.
Well,
good experience.
[inaudible]
when we had bitches,
we're here.
All right.
Fuck the end of the world.
The Shit did not materialize
the Mayans or bust,
they will go down in history like the
y two k cock suckers that May 11th guy.
All these assholes that called the end.
Nope.
Sorry.
You got to continue suffering.
Stupid.
Continue being confused.
Continue living your life with no answers.
That is the answer.
The answer is there's no fucking answer.
You're supposed to be,
yeah.
Terrified.
Yeah.
Red Bed when you out when
you're back in your seat.
Search a wiki deaths.
2012.
See who died on 12 2112.
Then for them it was the,
Oh shit.
This is right.
Yeah.
For them.
Oh my chest is seizing up.
Maybe we were one of those in a parallel
continuum and in this life we somehow
or another got through and
that's the path we followed.
But maybe in another life we all did.
Maybe it's true.
Maybe it is.
Maybe the end of the world did happen.
Well we can't remember it because we
didn't really truly experience it because
we moved onto the next and now
we don't have to pay our taxes.
That would be the Shit,
Huh?
If you woke up one day and all of a
sudden the whole tax system and the whole
monetary system made sense.
It's like it had been fixed.
It's not fixed now.
Oh,
okay.
Wouldn't it be beautiful,
be nice.
You think with all these
smart motherfuckers we have
running this world that
that would be possible if you
let the right people control it,
you know?
Is that possible?
Sorry.
Please hold me doing getting
out cash to pay that guy.
You're a guy.
I shouldn't say that guy.
He's coming back.
No.
Oh,
don't worry about
it.
We got that.
Don't worry.
We got that dude.
We got to like a company stack of cash.
Don't worry about it.
What do you use dealing
you son of a bitch.
All right,
well you're so rich.
You probably forget to that 10 bucks.
I a shit load of money and he's telling
him gambling addict and he just ran over
here with cigarettes for me so he can
play more scratch tickets and he's hoping
you notice and Stan Hope.
Good morning.
That's how you always look at it.
Did last night was awesome.
That was a one of the most fun
times I've ever had as a comedian.
I just wished we fucked
around with it a little more.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Like something goofy
like we're all together.
We should be doing
something goofy at the end.
Like the part may blue.
All our guys,
I tell stories or like
something that like didn't get,
makes it more than just how it,
here's three guys in a row.
But you,
we still around and took pictures
with everybody for hours.
I ever purposely didn't stand near you
cause they didn't want to create that.
No,
just you situation.
That's all ugly.
Yeah.
I just,
I just worked the lobby.
I Laughner well that's how it usually is.
We usually have like little packets of
people like Brian will have is a little
packet of people taking
pictures and Joey will have is,
but Joey will inevitably disappear back,
be right back.
Dog Vanish and he's always got some story.
I thought you were going
to meet me in the garage.
It's,
you are on the fucking highway.
Joey's the best vantage or ever cause
he just had to sub this is look at his
eyes.
He goes,
okay.
Salva Hesburgh was the best he would like.
He would disappear from
like a closed room.
I seal the,
and somehow hedbergs gone.
I remember we're in St cloud once,
we did a one nighter and
then we went to the bar.
We go to the 24 hour restaurant.
I go,
you get a booth,
it's a two in the morning.
And I said,
you get a booth and I'm just
going to use a pay phone.
This is how long ago was and not
call this girl that I had met.
And uh,
he goes,
okay.
And he goes in,
I look all over the restaurant.
I go,
as soon as he's in the men's room,
I get a menu.
I'm sitting there waiting.
He had left cause he thought,
oh you said you would call it a girl man,
I don't want to be a third wheel
sitting around him fucking
restaurant for an hour waiting.
Well he was probably just psyched.
It was like perfect opportunity to go
do smack the priest smack day if we're
doing a one night or in St,
cloud together,
the smack days start.
Uh,
the first time he ever
mentioned it to me was,
well I knew you knew by his act he'd
have his jokes and then the asides he'd,
you know,
so he goes,
do you ever have something that is good
but then you do something better and it
ruins a good thing.
Like I you like to smoke pot and then
someone that's sprinkled some heroin in
your pot and a regular pots,
no good anymore.
And so I knew would
he didn't just write that.
See that's why I won't
smoke pot with strangers.
Some creepy ass holes,
sprinkle some heroin.
And cause he think he's being goofy.
And then boom,
Du,
Du.
Did you ever had anything
that like addiction?
No.
No,
no.
Definitely.
Um,
I've never even touched anything
that I heard was addictive.
I mean,
alcohol is addictive,
but it seems to be addictive
for certain people only,
you know,
for me it's not at all.
But I've seen people that,
you know,
one drink in there,
they're gone.
They just don't switch goes
off and they're fucked.
But that seems to be very,
very variable.
But,
um,
like heroin,
never thought about it.
Coke never thought that anything.
And fet,
amines,
all that shit never appealed to me.
Just anything that where you go,
oh shit,
I couldn't live without that.
He's like sugar or no,
no,
I would,
I mean,
staples of life,
water and food.
Other than that,
I could live without almost everything,
you know?
Yeah.
I mean,
I think that's a weird connection that
people have to like certain things,
whether it's sugar or coffee or,
you know,
cigarettes are,
this is weird connections
that people have.
They like seek normalcy and repetitive
things and reoccurring themes in their
life and they just get connected to it.
There's people that will lose their
fucking mind if a bar they'd go to closes
down,
they'll lose their fucking mind.
Like it's the end of the world.
They don't know what the fuck to do.
The bars go in and if I still lived here,
I'd be like that about
the coach and coach.
So sad and I sick.
That place is fucking classic
because that place was a vortex to,
that's the place where Callan was out
in the front of the coach and horses and
he ran into an ex girlfriend that he
had who had turned into a streetwalker.
Wow.
That was deep.
I asked fucking deep.
I had that happen.
Uh Oh God,
what was his name?
There's Josh something.
It was a comic and it was playing Vegas
and I'd say five or six in the morning
now,
and there's a hooker at the bar and she,
she says,
do you want me to go up
to your room and danced?
And he says,
well,
what did he,
what are you going to do?
I mean,
are you going to dance?
I'm not prepaying you
that much money to dance.
What?
And she goes,
well,
are you a cop?
And he goes,
no,
I'm a comic.
She goes,
really?
Do you know Doug?
Stan hope that's a good girl.
And the ex old friend of mine,
his ex wife,
who I and I ended up banging after
they broke up once it was horrible.
And that hooker,
wow.
I was reading a story about
a woman who was an Olympian.
She was a two time Olympian,
I think for track and field.
And she was 40 years old and she
just decided to become a hook.
Suzy favor Hamilton.
Is that an area?
That's her name.
She's like a gold metal.
I guess she was a big deal on
the 2000 Olympics and now she's,
she was apparently,
I think they're trying to say
that it's antidepressants.
The turned her into a hooker.
She say she blamed
depression.
I don't know if she blamed
the actual medication.
Uh,
I think she was saying that the,
uh,
I think people were blaming Zoloft.
See,
I'm going to switch these headphones.
Did you ever hear that song from Weans
Zoloft as long it sounds like you're on
Zoloft when you're listening to it.
I feel like,
uh,
it's like very dreamy and the fork
I think if I remember really well.
I mean if you put it up
your bike well isn't that,
isn't that the thing about
it as it's supposed to get?
It's supposed to like relieve you
of any of the worries of life.
Like it takes all that shit away.
I got really anxious.
I,
I wasn't prescribed it,
but my dad was and what he died,
I,
I started taking them and
I just got a vague anxiety.
It gives you an anxiety if
you don't need a medication,
you don't know what it,
yeah.
She took Zoloft and once
you started taking Zoloft,
that allowed her to,
uh,
pursue Zoloft is the new Spanish fly.
Well,
you know,
that was the thing with McAfee and
believes what he was supposedly doing it.
He claims that it was all a ruse and
that it was all like he's a prankster and
he wasn't really cooking up bath salts
and he didn't really have a forum name
even though he had a formed
and it wasn't even his name.
It was like a,
I forget the stuff monger or something
like that was the the forum name,
so it wasn't like he was John
McAfee reporting live from beliefs.
It was just some dude wrote incredibly
detailed articles on extractions of m
DPV,
which apparently makes
people super duper sexual.
I read some stuff after I talked to you.
I haven't listened to the
podcast with them yet,
but I read a couple of
articles talking about it.
Did you get those the,
I sent you the links,
right?
Did I send you links
that you sent me legs,
but I haven't had time yet.
He's ridiculous.
I mean it's really a hilarious,
hilarious story,
but this MDPV apparently just makes me
want to scratch your dick off and makes
you just completely like just a
little crazed rabid fuck monkey.
Apparently.
It's just,
it's a constant thing while you're on it.
Even if you're not horny anymore,
you're like rubbing your dick raw.
I got him.
Get it.
Well,
yeah,
no,
I've done that with a lot of a lot
of drugs that do that to stimulants.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I've heard that.
I've heard with some
people like smoking crack,
like my friend Johnny
who had a crack problem,
he say,
I just like to smoke
crack and go beat off.
This was back in the day
when they had peep shows,
like he would go to a,
this was like times square,
like when it was really time square and
he would go down to the Pete booths when
he was smoking crack and he would just
stay in one of those things and keep
putting dollars in feeding dollars and
the thing and smoking crack and the girl
and he would beat off
and the growing like,
you know,
finger herself in front of him and shit.
I used to do that all in my youth.
Very dark.
Not The crack smoking,
but yeah,
go to s smudge shops and jerk off.
They'll want the sex world in Minneapolis
would have the live girls in the booth
and he'd in there.
What do you do to them?
You ask them.
They're sitting there on a bed or Dildos,
oh thing.
Whatever.
You're like,
I went to the lusty lady in
Seattle once with Dave Fulton.
I did a Gig and we want
to just go for that.
All right,
let's go in here and goof off and then
I'll sneak in what both and jerk off and
we ran into James in and randomly Edwin.
That's funny.
Is He?
He's not from Minneapolis,
right?
Where's he from?
He's,
he comes to Sydney.
He was in,
that was Seattle,
but he's back in Kansas City now.
He's a fucking insane person.
Kansas City is a fun town.
I haven't been in that
place in a long time.
I got to get back there.
That's a fun place.
I had a lot of fun there.
It says something about,
I think that's where I get herpes.
Pretty sure there's some weird
chick that looked like Ooma Thurman
therapies.
Extra long toes freak pitcher.
Too much.
Your actual own toes and your herpes.
Yeah.
People from Kansas City.
It's like Kansas City
is like a humble town,
you know,
they can't really brag too much.
That's Kansas City,
you know,
it's not New York.
It's not Chicago.
There's no debate anymore.
It's just Kansas City.
It's all good.
You can kind of judge it town by the,
uh,
by the,
they're,
they're sports fans.
Like yeah,
they have shitty teams,
but they still support him
like Chicago in the bears,
right?
Or Chicago and the,
the,
the white sox for the longest time.
But they've had some winning teams.
They're kind of Dicks,
but green bay years of futility.
But that stadium was sold out every
time and they're the happiest,
nicest people.
You're not going to get a lot
of stories out of green bay.
You're not going to get herpes in Greenbay
isn't that a funny thing about the
Midwest?
Like how fucking nice a lot
of the people are there.
I mean,
obviously it's a generalization,
but I think the overall tone of the people
just seems to be really fucking Nice.
Minnesota was calling
Douche bags everywhere.
People will tell,
you know,
tell people about some
somewhere being nice and like,
oh,
I went there and some guard punch from
your folk and foods and that can happen
anywhere as probably you could be you
and that should can happen anywhere.
You'll get always run into random people.
You can't like judge it
town based on one or two
incidences that you have you,
but your overall sense like when
you're in places like Wisconsin,
they're fucking nicest shit.
They're super nice.
Like everywhere you go,
people like really
reasonable down to earth.
Easy to talk to.
Yeah.
It's better.
It's better than being in New York,
being all fucking please be yourself.
Yeah.
You know,
I'm going a Yorker,
I'm a New Yorker,
you know,
nothing phases me.
How many yonker that is the one of the
grossest statements ever that I'm a New
Yorker.
I've seen it all.
I'm in New York or nothing.
Phases me.
Shot it.
Yeah.
The Hurricane Sandy was dye.
There was a lot of shot
and Freud and that.
The two weeks.
This is New York City in the world.
We shouldn't have power.
Yeah.
No,
it doesn't work that way.
Stupid.
It's just another fucking city.
It just
so happens that it's a really famous one.
But all the rules of cities apply.
And when cities get
fucking drowned in water,
it takes a long time to turn ship
back on and dry everything off.
Crazy fucks.
That place is going to go if that
happens again and again and again,
which had very well good.
And we had this guy on who's
talking about climate change.
Who was uh,
was it Shane Smith and
it was telling us this,
I think it was Shane Smith,
cause he's usually pretty doom
and gloom and my backpack.
Can you get me a stir in the front pack?
Um,
he was telling us that these,
these hundred year storms like Sandy,
he goes,
they're going to happen
three times a year.
Like that's,
that's the reality of climate change.
Three times a year.
You're gonna have hurricane Sandy's fuck
the east coast farm in the desert baby.
Yeah.
That's the way you're in a good spot.
You'll probably be tropical
in the next hundred years.
So you'll probably be in
a fucking rain forest.
Yeah.
What else?
What am I,
145.
I don't think that day's Kevin.
It's going to be really hot.
You never know,
man.
They might find some plant in the
Amazon that keeps you alive forever.
And then next thing you know,
global warming,
overpopulation,
Bisbee is the shit cause the move.
How often do you take shots into Maaco?
Uh,
almost never know,
but it's seven miles away,
right?
Yeah.
But the,
the town on the other side
is like nothing there.
The only reason you ever go over to that
town is to get prescription drugs and
they don't have a,
they have Xanax.
So that's it.
If I,
yeah,
if I needed Xanax or Viagara,
that would be the reason I went to,
and I have a script for it now.
So now when you do that and you
go over there and you get it,
how hard is it to bring it back?
You can bring up to,
they'll allow you to bring up to 30 pills,
uh,
across,
and sometimes they'll give you shit,
like,
do you need it?
You know,
you need a prescription for this.
And you go,
oh,
I have one.
And at one time I brought
my prescription bottle,
which had expired and I go,
yeah,
I got it right here.
And he goes,
this is expired.
You know you have,
but I know their policy is 30 pills
of any type of pill you can bring.
You know,
you can buy five different types of pills,
but as long as there's no
more than 30 they let you go.
So the guy's trying to
give me attitude and I,
but I know that I go,
so are you saying I
can't take these across?
I didn't say that.
All right.
So,
but normally you don't have any problems,
but I haven't
prescription now and I don't take them
often enough that I have to go get the
fake
refill across the board of the unnecessary
asshole security slash cop guy.
That is a really good
fortunate and aspect of our society.
The unnecessary asshole.
When you just like,
we could just talk,
everything can be fine.
You know,
you could just tell me what I,
what I can and can't do.
Well that's a,
that's the society we live it.
Look it up like kitchen
nightmares or bar rescue,
but it shows where,
okay,
if you want to help the guy
fixed his restaurant or bar,
you could just do it normally,
but no one's gonna Watch.
So you have to be a fucking dildo.
You've gotta be raided.
Yeah.
I have to be Gordon Ramsay,
Simon Style and asshole.
She has to get to watch cause
otherwise who'd care?
Yeah.
Isn't that funny?
What a,
what a weird aspect of society.
The uh,
the Douche bag,
the thinks he's allowed to
be a Douche bag because a,
you know,
he's being real or it's a part of the
job that we're fucking toughen up or this
and this is America.
There's no,
it's just where we have to keep you safe.
I need to know what
you're bringing across.
We have rules.
Those Xanax could kill babies
for baby ate all of those Xanax
fucking officer country
mcfuck face Douche bags,
but not all of them.
That's the problem.
So cool.
The clanking of my ice,
just in my head.
No,
it's beautiful.
All right,
sounds good.
Beautiful.
Sounds romantic.
No carrot.
Let's,
you know,
Brian had a podcast.
Some chick insists on eating carrots.
Eliza slash that nothing
makes me more rage.
Well,
she had a little dog with her
little dog in her lab bench.
He used to fuck you proper.
Let's set you straight.
Not that I really believe that,
man.
I think that's cool.
I think last night's buzz
is hitting back in now.
I feel pretty fucked up right now.
I bet.
Yeah.
Last night was fun,
man.
That was,
uh,
that,
that whole show.
First of all,
it was an interesting
twist having honey honey,
having a band opened for us.
It made the whole thing feel like a
totally different sort of experience,
you know?
So that worked well because it is,
I know most times when he
mixed music with comedy,
it always seems to be annoying.
But yeah,
but you know,
oh,
something that we were,
we were talking about last night,
me and Eddie were like that with some
shows and some crowds that might be the
case.
Like you might not,
it might not mix to have music.
I've traveled with a couple of guys,
Miss Michigan Shambala who I fucking
love and he's a Solo Act Guitar and a lot
of songs have fit my crowd drinking,
you know,
hardcore,
uh,
almost like boot Koski s songs and uh,
the Matt Boyd who is just
as weird guy from Finland,
that was really crazy,
but it didn't work.
Touring like,
all right,
one night last night was perfect because
it was a hyped show that everyone's
there,
they know what's going on,
they know that it's going
to be music and comedy,
but when we were touring show
up in whatever Fuck Ville,
Tennessee and they're like,
that guy's not funny.
He's not supposed to be funny.
It's music.
Some people,
yeah,
it hasn't been promoted enough
that you know what to expect.
Yeah.
As long as it's good.
I mean some people would
just so fucking tight minded.
They're so closed minded when it comes
to what they want to see and what they
don't want to see.
But it's what they're trained to expect.
Exactly too.
So like when Michigan would have
songs that are vaguely funny,
then they think he's,
you know,
supposed to be Henry
Phillips and they're like,
well,
he's not supposed to.
If it happens to be funny in the song,
that's part of it,
but it's
not his job.
But you can't,
like you're the only one you trust to
go out and tell the audience and as the
headline or you can open up and go,
okay,
I'm going to open the show and
then closed the show later on.
But I have to explain to you fucking
nitwits what's about to happen.
Yeah,
well the crowds that we,
uh,
attract though,
that doesn't seem to be a problem at all.
Like,
um,
this last night,
obviously it was a hype show
and it was sort of a big event.
So I don't know if it's indicative
of how to work every time,
but it's,
it seemed to be so smooth.
A theater show is different than the
shit I was doing where playing some goofy
rock and roll bars out of a van.
Yeah,
dude,
there's good things and bad
things about theater shows.
It was really interesting.
We did a show a Thursday
night at the Improv and a,
these people came up to me and they said,
this is the first time they'd
seen me in a comedy club.
They only see me and they saw me in
Austin and they sent me somewhere else.
I think I've only seen in
these big places like the,
the guy was like,
it's way better in a small place.
Oh,
it's all.
Yeah,
it really is the money.
We're all the same that I do.
I do 75 seaters.
Really?
75 you think that fucking Velveeta
Room in Austin like I would love,
is that 70 how many
think it's 65 70 people.
Wow.
But it's so close and intimate and you,
it's,
it's like,
you feel like the life of
the party rather than a paid,
you know,
this something.
But there's the other side of it is
there's something crazy about doing,
like it's a different sort of a show,
but when you do a crowd like last
night where it's whatever it is,
2000 screaming fucking
people going bananas.
There's something about that too,
like when you're brushing felt so removed,
like you couldn't see
anybody even leaning in.
It was hard to see a face.
It's certainly a different experience.
It's definitely the big,
the big theaters are way different
experience we had in the UK.
We were doing all theaters,
most of them.
We had no business playing.
We're not going to sell out a 2000
seat or in Sunderland Ingo but someone
thought it was a great idea but,
but a few of them like Wolverhampton,
it's still my favorite city in the UK.
Go Wolverhampton Wolves.
Yes.
That's my team.
Just because the show is so great.
We,
it was like a small like Beatles thing
getting from the back door into the van
where they're like slapping on
the side of the van afterwards.
This is crazy.
Wow.
Yeah.
Great.
Hampton.
Wolverhampton.
Wow.
And we knew it was going to
be great cause everyone goes,
oh you're going to Wolverhampton.
Oh good luck.
They're there for,
that's what I was going to be our place.
If you hate it.
We like it isn't funny.
Look that fucking Detroit
is always great shows.
And everyone's like,
it's got such a bad rep,
but if fucking grade his fans,
he pulled this one thing
though that people do.
There's something they love about being
in a giant group of people experiencing
the same thing at the same time.
Like if you go to see a band,
you know,
I've seen bands and intimate
settings and it's pretty bad ass,
but I've also seen him in front of
thousands of people and there's something
like,
yeah,
crazy trick about that,
you know?
Yeah.
It's,
it's just,
it's good to have him bolt.
It's good to have the same,
you know,
it's good to have big,
giant crazy crowds,
but it's also good to just
show up someplace and do a,
you know,
a 1:00 AM spot of the stolen.
It's nice when you can go
out afterwards and you know,
take a lot of pictures,
but you spent probably twice as long
taking pictures as you did on stage.
Yeah,
probably.
That's almost impossible when you said,
we're going out front.
I'm like,
you're fucking kidding me.
You're going to go shakes is 1700 hands.
I don't even know what the,
I figure if they want to wait
in line and they paid to see me,
I'll fucking no hanging out.
I'm not going to,
I never,
I never thought to do the makeup,
a line situation.
I just go out into absolute
chaos after a show.
Even I was like 300 people.
But I like,
it's just so it's everyone like
can I get a picture of this way?
Like I don't know what
camera I'm looking at.
Yeah,
well that was how I always did it.
But live nation just took
over and started making lines.
That's what it was.
Cause I would just go out and
they would go care you got,
you're going to go out and do that again.
And then I'd go,
yeah,
probably.
And they're like,
okay,
let me,
let's,
can we set up a line and said okay,
go ahead and set up a line.
And they usually have that one guy that
knows how to use every single on camera.
It was like
that's a problem as people
in their fucking droid.
So they have no idea how to use them.
But what's the give a droid to someone
who's never used a droid and they look at
that shit and like warthog
which one's the can't?
What's that?
Cause they can have the exact
same icons and exact same place.
So like the camera buttons bigger
and it's on the lefthand side.
You're like,
what the fuck is this?
Where's the flash and the flash here?
I still do that.
Just trying to dial my phone.
Which one?
Contacts or droid,
is that what that is?
That's a,
that's the big screen one
yesterday for online man.
No,
I think he's got a,
what is that?
Which one is the razor?
It was the biggest one song.
That's the last three.
And I still like,
that's the biggest one I could get.
And I only get it because I was forced
into what world where I have to text and
it's still not big enough for my thumbs.
I is a typo in every fucking
word because my thumbs are fat.
How long you've been doing it?
I've had this like,
uh,
about a year.
So you're so behold over here.
Brian and I had been typing in those
fucking things for years and years and
years.
So we're like [inaudible]
we just get used to it.
Know while you're driving.
No,
no,
I don't.
I don't fuck with my phone while I'm
driving and you should need law here.
It should be a law.
Don't fucking text while you're driving,
not texting,
just talking on the phone.
Even that these fucking
people cover half their face.
Get a little plugs,
stick in your ear.
Stupid.
These people are ridiculous.
They were like holding their
left hand up to their window,
their car window and driving and they
literally can't see the whole left side.
I believe it's been proven that it's
not the actual holding the phone that
causes the accident.
It's because you're paying
attention to the conversation.
So the fucking ear piece,
it's all bullshit.
It is.
But you,
you are in a disadvantage if you can only
hold the steering wheel with one hand,
if that's the only way you can do it.
And if you're holding
a phone up to your ear,
it's not.
You mean you have to throw the phone
down and grab that takes too much time.
All right.
That's the fact.
It's too,
it's not safe and it's one thing.
You're holding a drink.
If I'm holding a coffee
and I see an accident,
I'll let that fucking coffee going.
You're not going to throw your
phone down and grabbed this.
That's why I walk everywhere.
That my announcement.
No sentence.
Maybe you wouldn't drop
your coffee either.
You'd probably just crash.
Make any sense at all.
Probably
easier to drop your phone.
Terrific.
Studies with Doug and Joe will be back
after we're going to go start an accident
with coffee and a phone.
I just one thing of all and someone
out there do this because I have the,
I have all these great ideas that
are going to die in my brain,
but someone go out and take an 80
year old sober guy on a course,
you know,
obstacle,
obstacle course,
but a driving course and put
them next to a spry 25 year old,
uh,
twice the legal driving limit.
Yeah.
And See who drives better on a
and a controlled.
Yeah.
It's a good idea.
I love that that youtube clip would get
a lot of fucking hits and a lot of lot
of controversy.
So real problem with us allowing old
people to continue to drive like well,
well,
well into dementia,
you know,
cause there's no,
no one gets in there and stops him.
And I mean how many times we've heard
about like that Santa Monica woman,
that dude hit the gas and
ran over all those people.
And another one happened recently
where a guy knocks and people over,
we called the cops,
which I like it,
it killed me to have to call
the cops on a drunk driver.
But we were following someone from Bisbee
to Tucson on a two lane and over the
line and then into the
breakdown lane over the line.
And I go,
if I don't call the cops and this
person's swerves into oncoming traffic,
how much of a deck am
I going to feel like?
So I called the cops and
they didn't get there before.
There's a border checkpoint we have to
go through to get from our house to the
Tucson airport.
And when we got to the
checkpoint we get to,
it was like an 89 year old.
Whoa.
Just a hunchback,
most elderly woman.
And I'm like,
what?
So she wasn't even drunk?
No,
no,
it was just fucking old.
Oh my God.
Who is terrifying and wish you
and one of those really old cars.
It's like real loose.
Like those old like no,
no,
no.
She No,
she had a normal car.
She'll,
yeah.
Old Cars.
Have you ever tried to
drive like a really old,
like Shitty Oldsmobile?
Remember the one I bought it,
the band shell that was pair,
I bought it.
I had to go to Fresno to pick it up
as a 1980 dodge aspen that had the,
the roof it off,
uh,
and painted lime green with
a big white racing stripe.
And I just,
I bought this on purpose to fuck with
Rogan cause he had just got this $120,000
Porsche.
So I parked it right next.
We had a parking space is
side by side on the man.
She'll lot.
So I've bought the biggest piece
of Shit I could find on Ebay,
the loudest,
ugliest,
stupid
his car and had the prop department
makeup a bumper sticker that said,
I'm with Rogan,
with an Arrow towards your car.
And I still have that bumper
sticker on my refrigerator now.
Uh,
I remember,
I remember that,
but it was terrifying.
It's the speed limit should go
by the quality of your vehicle.
It shouldn't just be a blanket thing.
So fucking loon lake.
Yeah,
there's old cars like
with drum brakes and shit.
Those things are really sketchy.
Everybody you know,
has one bill burr.
Bill burr has a really old Ford,
I think it's a Ford pickup truck,
like a 1950 something
pickup truck where it's a,
it's a manual transmission
where you shifted on,
on the stalk,
you know,
it's like,
so you're like,
you're pulling a lever that's
attached to the steering wheel.
It's craziness and he loves it.
The joy and sparkle in his eyes,
you know,
it's like I go,
well,
you know,
navigation system,
fucking no navigation system.
It's like,
it does everything.
I think the radio works.
It was just his old Angie's
like you could work on it,
look at the open and hope I can
work on that fucking bill burr.
Just talking to them.
It just about whatever.
I don't even remember what
we were talking about,
but right before I went on stage and
just everyone in the green room is just
dying laughing and he's just talking
casually about whatevers and then I get to
go on stage after this and nothing
in my act as is funny as just him.
Kibitzing yeah,
he's a,
he's such an awesome dude too.
You know he liked,
didn't want,
he didn't want to hang.
It's like,
oh,
I don't want to,
you know.
Zynga went out and got him.
He was leaving and he said,
I don't want to impose
like fuck outta here.
Come hang out with us.
You want us to be completely overrun by
industry and no one fund in the green
room.
It was a weird green
room and talking about,
we're talking about this,
I think we talked about this
before the podcast started.
We didn't know fucking
half the people in there.
It was weird.
It's like all these industry people,
I thought they were all Europe people.
Joey d is talked me out of even going,
he's like,
talk,
you don't want to go down there.
I'm like,
and I thought it was like,
all right,
there's some creepy sex shit.
Well,
Stan hope scared off most of them from
the after party by bringing in strangers.
Standups went out and
grabbed some strangers.
They had this giant spread of food that
you know there's going to go straight in
the trash.
Jeff wills assured me it
goes to the homeless people.
I'm like,
yeah,
I'm sure that's what you're thinking
about while you're counting the beans at
the end of the night is oh,
make sure the cold cuts get to the
homeless just to just drop him off of the
corner of skid row.
Flop.
Yeah,
and there's like three cases of beer
and it's just us in the industry,
so I've just got people out of your line.
I go,
he'll be down here eventually
come drink free beer.
So Stan,
he'll grab a bunch of people,
brought them down to the after party
and smoked out all the industry people.
Eventually like I'm on and I'm calm.
I'm uncomfortable here.
I'm talking about my pending deals.
Really.
I didn't know most of the
people that were back there.
It was like my manager and my agent
and there's like a bunch of strangers.
That was Shandra,
that was my managers.
Who's your,
who's the cleaners?
Hussman Sas.
I was talking to the wrong call.
Sussman.
I was talking to the guys from,
uh,
impractical jokers.
I don't know if you've seen it.
What does that sound like?
A prank show on true TV,
which is a fucking awful network.
It's the only good thing on the network.
But it's like,
it's genuinely funny there
for friends and they just,
the prey,
they pull pranks on people.
But the idea is to,
we're gonna make our friend go do this.
And then they like,
so it's really,
the prank is out there
fucking with each other.
It's really funny.
I soft,
genuinely funny and they,
I was talking to them cause they,
they have some problems with the network
that make them man show look fucking
like we owned it.
Really?
Yeah.
And I'm like you gotta get a
guy like fucking Rogan's guy.
We called him the cleaner.
I couldn't think of his name.
Yeah,
you,
you need someone to call like the network
telling them what to do on their off
time and oh my God,
really the tell them what
to do on their off time.
Like what?
Like they were like they were
going to do a Gig in Iowa.
They have like five shows booked
in Iowa just on their own.
We couldn't let him use the
impractical jokers name.
Then they told them they couldn't even
do the gig because they wanted them to be
focused on the show even
though they're not taping.
It was like crazy.
You remember when we first
sat down to do the mantra,
one of their first ideas was that we film
the beginning of it in Iraq and we go
over and do the man show in Iraq.
I don't remember that.
And I was like,
I go,
oh,
that was their idea on Stanley's idea.
And I go,
are you out of your fucking mind?
I go,
you want to go to a war zone and have
girls jump up and down on trampolines?
And I go,
what are you doing?
Are you endorsing this
invasion of this country?
That makes no fucking sense.
That's supposed to be connected to
nine 11 but isn't really in any way,
shape or form.
Is that what we're doing?
And we just sat there and looked at
me like they didn't know what to say.
I go,
what the fuck are you talking about?
That was like the beginning
of the end with those guys.
I do remember when we were going to get
Oj Simpson on to do Andy Rooney spot at
the end of every show
and just announce him,
his Heisman trophy winner,
Oj Simpson,
and then he just bitches
about ATM fees or something.
Is it just money?
You're getting money from me anyway.
Why are you going to,
so Stanley had some connection
to them where he's like,
no,
that's no possible way off the table.
You know?
That's,
that should have never happened.
We fucked up,
man.
We,
that was an interesting lesson,
but what happened was,
first of all,
if anybody does the history of the show,
I was doing fear factor at the same time.
So my time was very
limited and I was fucked.
Um,
and the other thing was
they kind of bullshitted us.
They told me when I was setting up,
when,
when they were sending it out for me,
they were like,
listen,
you could do whatever the fuck you want.
Like if you guys get sued,
that would be good for us.
It'd be good publicity.
They go,
I go,
what about nudity?
Can we blow it out?
Absolutely.
Nudity.
We'll blur it out.
Swears sweat would just beep it out.
Do whatever the fuck.
Stanley,
the production company,
no,
they don't stand on.
He literally said to me,
if we get sued,
it would be great.
It would be great publicity.
I was like,
this is perfect.
And then I'm saying you deal
with Stan help and they yes.
If Steven Steinhouse what you want to go.
The only way I'm doing
it is with stand up.
Okay,
good.
We're in.
And then once we got,
and Oh my God,
it was just,
they lied to us.
It was like the network had these
really silly idea was it was so
compartmentalize that you have,
you know,
the network saying one thing,
then you have the stolen Stanley's
saying another thing and then there's the
lawyers and then there's
standards and practices.
So you couldn't get a cohesive answer.
One person might be genuinely saying,
yeah,
you can do whatever you want.
Hang on Duns Helberg our
lawyer says you can't do that.
But it was the idea that the the most,
the,
the thing that I didn't expect the most
was these people who weren't funny in
any way,
shape or form telling you what is and
isn't funny and telling you like sketches
that are and aren't funny and you're like,
what do you,
what do you even saying?
Like when did you become
an expert on what's funny?
Like you don't,
you have no idea what it would
take to put something down,
write it down on paper,
conceptualize it in a way that
the audience is gonna absorb it.
Go on stage and kill.
You don't understand what that is.
Oh,
I know what that is.
That's,
that's my job.
That's your job.
I don't want to talk too much about
the impractical jokers stories.
I don't,
I don't know how much I'm
talking out of school,
but like the fucking head of the network,
mark jurists,
this dose,
we'll make them fucking write out possible
improv things they might say under
these circumstances.
Okay,
we approve the gag,
so what jokes might you say to someone
in and it will approve things that might
or might not be sad,
so he improves possibly fucking
almost in tears on the phone call.
I don't know how to do this.
I go,
I don't know what to tell you.
Is He?
That is someone who's a Douche bag who
doesn't understand that your creative
process in any way,
shape or form.
If you're out there and you
work with something creative,
there's one way,
only one way.
You can get the most out of that person.
Leave him alone.
It's it.
Leave me alone.
Let them come up with their
own shit and that's it.
It's the only way.
It's going to work.
If you start meddling,
you're not going to make it better.
You're not,
you're not going to
fucking straighten out the,
the plot lines.
You're not,
you're not.
If they're funny,
they're going to have
figure out how to do it.
If they work on it hard,
if they,
they care about it,
they'll make it good.
If they,
they can't,
they suck.
And you're not going to fix that.
You're not going to fix suck and
you're not going to make funny,
funnier.
You're just not.
Me and bill were talking about that,
about we're getting to a level where,
you know what?
I can just do standup.
I don't need to be on TV.
I can make that,
uh,
you know enough money now
as a standup where fuck you.
Yeah.
I feel like that with
everything except the UFC,
the UFC,
the like,
they're like a family to me.
Like Dana and,
yeah,
but that's not a game where they go,
okay,
you have to do this and
this and this and where,
no,
no.
I mean it's like it's the easiest Gig
of all time from me because I'm this
passionate,
fanatical fan.
But as far as like,
I mean anything else,
like I don't give a fuck.
Like I got,
I've been offered movies
before and I'm like,
well I don't want to do that.
I'm going to how to go to
New Orleans for a month.
The fuck am I going to get sell trailer?
Yeah.
I have no desire.
I like,
if the level of fame that I had two
years ago was all I could ever get to,
I'm good with that.
I'm,
I'm not even famous.
I'm uncomfortable with
the amount of fame have,
you're unquestionably famous,
not famous.
Walk down the street.
That's better because you're
famous among standing Examity fan.
I'm perfect.
There's a,
there's a elite group of
human beings you know,
that are like in this,
this one category that I consider funny
and there's not that many of them.
You know,
there's like a,
it's really kind of amazing if
you stop and think about it.
If you think about how many
people were actually on the,
I just got a text,
I just wanted to make sure it wasn't Q.
Listening from the practical jokers gold.
You're going to get us fired,
man.
Fuck man.
True TV pays my mortgage,
man.
What else is on true TV?
All the fake,
it shows in their world fake as shit.
Hardcore pawn is completely fucking fake.
Set up mystery diners was one.
They would run it where
they watch a bad employee.
It's like slap you in the face.
Insulting leave.
Poorly staged.
Wow.
They'll have a bad employee and we think
he's stealing and now we have video
for,
we set up hidden cameras and
we see him stealing things.
And uh,
w we watched one where the guy,
oh,
he's caught him and his friends
are carrying a keg out the back.
Well,
when they're going out the
door from the inside shot,
that keg is not tapped.
But on the other side of the door,
the keg is tap.
So we called them,
we called up and we go,
ah,
yeah,
I need to talk to that employee,
Jed,
whatever the guy's name was.
Uh,
yeah,
we saw the show,
I think because he was serving
underage people and we go,
yeah,
I think he served my
underage daughter and I'm,
I'm going to take legal action.
And then fucking manager.
I had to tell me outright,
no,
that show's completely stage.
Yeah,
no,
they hide.
Those are hired to actors.
That's funny.
Do you remember being okay,
I got another one of these.
Thank you.
My Love the,
do you remember I'm a
governor's on long island.
Yes.
He a dude who worked at governors who
was a wicked cool guy who was a doorman
who also doubled.
He,
they would fly him out and he
would do various talk shows and uh,
they had a deal.
They would call him up and then go,
hey,
we're looking for a guy who was in
love and is having an affair with his
brother's wife.
And he'd be like,
what the fuck do you know?
I am in love?
And having an with my brother,
his wife,
and he would just fly down
and they would just sit.
I do with Jerry Springer.
And you did it?
I did that Springer when it first started,
like yeah,
I did Springer.
And then while I was there,
the fucking uh,
producer guy,
just fucking crazy.
I actually got sued by him later on.
Uh,
he said,
uh,
he goes,
okay,
we're going over the script.
It's me and two strippers that are
pretending to be strippers probably.
And uh,
we are going over the,
you know,
rehearsing.
They flew me out for free
is 1998 or something.
And uh,
he said,
and by the way,
don't talk to anyone in the hotel
because a 20 twenty's investigating us or
dateline and a,
so if anyone comes up to you,
and it was such a Dick that the
next morning I called my agent,
I go get me a number for 20,
20.
And then it turned into this whole like
spy versus spy where I'm leaving the
outline snuck out under my door.
So 2020 can come grab it and copy it and
then put it back while I'm in the other
room rehearsing.
It was fucking crazy.
And then I,
yeah,
it just,
it was a whole,
the stories on my website,
somewhere in the archives happened to
that really fucking funny show you did for
Fox.
That hidden camera show
where you cooked a cat.
Yeah.
You brought a cat too.
Was that what has tried to mail my,
yeah.
My,
my ex girlfriend says
she wants her cat back.
So I went to him like mailing mailboxes,
et cetera.
At a male it was what
looked like a dead cat boy.
Did they mail it for you?
I don't remember
as a montage of different places.
That show was funny.
Think anyone mailed it.
That was in the 90s right?
Let's say we,
we filmed it in [inaudible] 99 and it
didn't air until 2001 they just shelved
it.
But then they pulled it out
as a summer replacement.
It was right,
it was after nine 11 because they changed
it from attack of the hidden cameras
to invasion of the hidden cameras.
Cause they thought attack was
too strong in a post nine 11
oh God.
Oh God.
I hate everybody.
I fucking love him.
The camera and that.
None of it's good.
Yeah,
that's definitely,
that's why I love impractical jokers.
It's finally like after years of punk
and you just want to leap through the TV
and slap that fucking Ashton Kutcher
and his mouth and then the car off,
right?
Yeah.
This,
we set up a fake valet.
What idiot is just going to give
their keys to a random stranger?
Really?
You don't Valet Park your fucking car.
Ashton could cheer you spar me cut like
smarmy and there were just so like so
poor I fucking candid camera.
I want to get like box sets of old
candid camera cause this shit makes me
fucking cry.
Laugh candid camera
was pretty fucking bad.
Yes.
Yeah.
It's a,
there's not that is it?
What is the deal with
a hidden camera though?
There's like certain rules that exist
now that I don't think existed before was
reasonable expectation of privacy.
Oh,
I gotta fucking tell you
a story off of there.
I have the injection,
my backpack
of why I can't tell you why
there I got a story off the air.
I remember the fake Doctor
Phil that we had for the man.
Yeah,
it was fucking brilliant.
That was funny.
Shit.
Yeah.
He had an earpiece.
He just looked like he was,
he was a brilliant impress you.
Oh,
he did.
Dot.
Hold it off.
Those women really thought
it was doctor Phil,
but that was fucking awesome dude.
That was like one of my favorite things.
We did that.
And uh,
when you stole the old Mancho
midget when your romance to Arturo.
Oh,
that was beautiful too.
I got the master tapes.
I want to,
I want to put them on Ebay
because they won't release our,
you know,
our show ever the case.
They won't release it.
They would have,
they've released every
other one on box at DVDs.
I know.
I just want,
I just want to Ebay that
the tapes for charity.
That's not a bad idea.
He probably get sued though.
Why?
I don't know.
Because so many probably owns it.
And if they over wanting
to sell it as a d,
Why did they give me the fucking tapes?
I probably fucked up.
They didn't think you were crazy and going
like they didn't understand what Ebay
was.
Probably.
They probably didn't have email back then.
I did another court problem right now.
Yeah,
don't do it because if we don't,
if we an Andy or flying
to Florida for Christmas,
that's how we realized we will be spending
our Christmases in court in Florida,
in court,
in Florida.
We've flagged Christmas Day.
Forget.
We can't talk about it.
Oh,
is this that thing that you
were talking about before?
Yeah.
Oh,
someone's upset shouldn't
have been fucking kids,
pal.
It's how it goes.
Right.
I wouldn't say any son of a bitch.
I don't even know what
we're talking about.
I'm just making things up folks.
If this in any way coincidentally
relates to the actual events of the case,
it's a don't,
don't worry.
After after we're out of court,
it's,
yeah,
we'll be able to talk.
Yeah,
we're good.
So it could become a part
of your act 20 minutes.
That's a problem.
That's the problem.
When you have a great story,
but it's with another comic
and it's pretty much his story.
Well you,
here's what you do with that guy.
Don't fucking lay it
out for him and say it.
And the perfect joke for him.
Yeah,
he'll have his own take,
but he's been making
jokes about it for years.
Let's get off because this is
not only that,
we're already probably
tripping on some legal issues.
You can consult with Jay more
though if you need help with it.
Speaking of fucking hilarious.
Uh,
I sent Doug this thing and
this is a video of Bill Burr,
um,
talking about Yoko Ono and John Lennon
and it is one of the fucking funniest
things I've ever seen.
Like you to keep that.
Yeah.
We're going to,
we're going to show it cause it's,
it's,
it's so perfect.
It was when John Lennon had a chance to
perform on a television show with Chuck
Berry and he brought Yoko Ono with
them and bill Burgess breaks it down.
It's one of the fun
you to see it visually.
Folks,
two of you,
you're listening to this on iTunes.
Do yourself a favor and just youtube
bill burr Yoko Ono and find the clip and
watch it because the look on Chuck
Berry's face is fucking priceless.
I mean it's priceless.
Chuck Berry,
Yoko Ono about the Beatles
and how great is this?
The video was whatever you want to say.
I totally agree with them.
I think that the greatest
band of all time,
but I have to be honest with you.
John Lennon and Paul McCartney
redefined pussy whipped.
You have to watch this fucking video.
It's
John Lennon is singing with Chuck Berry.
Chuck Berry is probably one of
the main reasons why John Lennon,
Lennon ever picked up a guitar.
He's on TV.
He gets to play with this idol.
They're playing.
Uh,
Chuck Berry's hit Memphis.
Okay.
John Lennon's got Yoko
in his fucking band.
They're in the middle of singing this
song on television and the killing it.
It's going great.
Yoko's playing some stupid fucking drum.
And even though she has no
fucking talent whatsoever,
he's putting her in the fucking band.
Just she'll,
she'll shut the fuck up and stop nagging
him cause he's too much of a fucking
pussy to tell her that she has no talent.
All right.
The only reason why you're here
Yoko's cause just sucking my dick.
All right.
No,
you can't play the bongos.
But anyway,
she's up to playing the Bongos,
right?
So John Lennon,
Chuck Berry to the greats of all time
harmonizing singing this hit from the
1950s that's what this is about.
And Yoko in the middle
of it can't handle that.
She's not getting any shine.
She takes the fucking
microphone out of the stands,
starts playing the Bongo
and as they're singing,
you know,
go,
go Johnny go whatever.
She picks up the mic
and I swear to God goes
some fucking crazy shit.
And you see Chuck Berry's eyes
fucking open as wide as they are.
And it's that.
It's that fucking look dude.
You have to have like a
buddy of yours and he's,
he's,
he's dating some fucking psycho,
but he's in love with her.
So you can't fucking say anything and
you're just sitting there waiting for the
fucking lightning bolt to hit your friend
in the head where he finally realizes
that he's dating a psycho cunt.
Chuck Berry had that look on his face.
I'm not even joking.
I'm not even an exaggeration.
That's what the fuck she did.
And Chuck diaries like what the fuck?
And it's kind of like John,
that's your woman get her in line.
And John Lennon does not even fucking,
he doesn't even blink.
He just,
he just keeps playing and then she
does it again later on in that song.
And then you look at all the other
musicians and they just keep playing the
song.
Like Yoko isn't even fucking there.
And uh,
I actually get infuriated when I watched
this video of the fact that John didn't
just stop playing in that moment.
And what he should have done
was dressed or down right there.
Yes.
I find you want to have a fucking moment.
This is your mom.
If you ever do that again,
I will slap you so
fucking hard in the head.
Your eyes are going to look like mine
standing play that fucking Bongo and you
shut your face.
You look like that bitch.
You crawled out of the
fucking well in ring stand me.
I didn't mean why I'm fucking,
you are going to be fucking,
anybody can't play the pong ball goes.
You can't say shut your fucking face.
And then he just walks back up to the
mic and just counts the band back in.
Is that what the fuck
you should have done?
Beautiful.
Okay.
Bingo.
Bingo is here.
I told Rogan I go out.
Anytime we get into a like a
really strong riff together,
I'm going to have bingo.
Lean into the mic and just go
right.
Oh my God.
That's,
so I went to a Yoko Ono art exhibit in
Massachusetts once when I was living in
Boston.
They had some things set up somewhere.
It was the most ridiculous shit I had.
Eh,
I,
I didn't know what to expect.
I just,
I was going there hoping that
there'll be something funny and uh,
I go there and one of the art pieces was
a block of wood with some nails in it
and there was a box of nails and a hammer
that was the piece of art.
And she said that she wanted it,
she was encouraging people to participate
and they should pick up a nail and put
it into the block of wood.
And that was the art.
Yeah.
This reminds me of what you
went to the wine tasting.
Yeah.
What kind of Super Pussy did she have?
The captain morale.
What was going on there?
It's not what it was.
I mean,
was he just not even like hot Asian
and it's hard to be not hot and Asian.
Yeah.
It's difficult.
She was gross.
She was weird.
It was a strange fucking,
it's almost like she
hypnotized him or something,
you know?
Yeah.
Sometimes when you,
you do,
you know,
hardcore hallucinogens with someone,
maybe you see something in
them that no one else can see.
Even if it's not really there.
Maybe it was,
this bitch is not going anywhere.
Maybe it was one of those,
it was like,
look,
I need you
somewhat.
I need to make sure you're going
to be around for a long time.
You know,
can we,
can we bank on this?
You know,
I don't know John.
I'm like the wind.
I go where my conscience takes me.
I don't know.
Yup.
Head with chicks that I,
because I thought there was another
level to them that I'm not finding yet.
And you go,
no,
you're just a fucking empty
shell of a human being.
It's not like you're not
giving me more and you're,
you're,
you're not secret.
You're hoping there was more
that you would just dilute,
take that initial infatuation and like,
oh,
okay.
Convinced that there's
something more that I'm,
you're not giving me.
I expect more from my heroes is do.
It makes me sad.
I mean like firemen and shit,
you know,
like,
like John Lennon.
Oh,
I expect the more I thought
you meant me that was going to,
no,
not,
you
know me and I'm very happy.
I thought you were saying that.
I,
I let you down by staying with
women that were fucking subpar.
No,
you did an awesome job
with everything so far.
My issues with John Lennon and Yoko Ono
and the fucking block of wood with nails
in it.
I remember just standing there sitting
there like what kind of bullshit is this?
How is this art?
It's a box of nails and a fucking hammer.
Speaker
performance.
No chance.
Is that Dick Cabot?
Yeah.
Off of Dick Cavett look
at this little esoteric,
I don't understand a fucking word.
We are water.
A lot of money.
I wonder if you just stretch.
I love that though.
I love cause I have horrible teeth so I
love seeing like back then you've actors
that have great teeth
now had these fucking
horrible wrecked fucking miles and the
true sixties and seventies and I missed
her.
I love being in the UK.
Like I can be ugly as shit and
be on TV like Jeremy Clarkson.
I Dunno who that is.
You got from top gear,
you never watched the show top gear,
but is he the fatter,
bigger one?
Yeah,
I,
I don't remember his mouth
but funny fucking dude is he,
he's funny man.
He's very funny.
You don't give a fuck about cars.
But then that is not really about
car in the UK you don't have,
you don't have the choice of giving
a fuck cause they only have like nine
channels and you're stuck in a hotel all
day and you don't want to go out cause
there's nothing to eat and the fucking
beers are overpriced and everyone's
surely in the pub.
So you watch TV.
I watch music videos over there.
Someone is a little on
the negative side today.
Do you feel this,
do you ever heard the song down
with the trumpets by Rizal kicks?
No,
that's a fucking,
it's,
I like it now because I hated it so
much and I watched a video so many times
over five weeks and in
London that it became like,
why do you torture
yourself with those long,
long tours like that?
Like five a young.
Well,
I in the states,
we've been this year we went
back old school and just put,
yeah,
me and two other comics and Charlie,
my road manager and Bingo in a van and
just went town to town and we had a
fucking blast.
I heard the dude who's opening for you,
who opened for you at the comedy store.
It's really fun.
Junior stop.
Go.
Oh,
he's bucking.
He's my,
my new fucking guys.
You have anything online?
Can you?
But it's nothing.
Nothing quality.
No.
Uh,
is no quality footage.
But junior stopped.
[inaudible].
S t o p.
K.
A fucking wicked funny.
Is this the video?
Nice guy.
O p.
K A.
Pka.
No.
Friendless up.
It
comes up with,
so we don't want to
break
internet.
That's all right.
That was pretty good,
man.
God Rizal Kicks Down with the trumpet and
data that became an obsession with you
while you were looking at I
got the video bothered me.
The kids bothered me.
Do you know the rules to wash itself?
No,
I don't.
I didn't get that deep sneaker.
I watched it watch darts either.
Yeah.
I've watched a watch,
an hour and a half of snooker.
I did get into football over there.
I mean soccer.
Yes.
I know.
I still like I have bits that I wrote
over there and I still have to when I do
and I'm over here,
stopped myself from saying football
and say soccer or you know those those
buzzwords.
It's like saying nigger over there.
If you call it soccer,
you'll get worse reaction from saying
soccer about football on stage in the UK
than any racial slur or Ealing soccer.
Huh?
He's fucking football.
You're fucking whoa.
Easy.
That's all they have.
[inaudible] is a smarter football.
Really.
Those guys don't get as much brain damage,
but problem with American football man
is just fucking helmets apparently said,
everybody says that they
took off the helmets.
They wouldn't be slamming head.
Exactly.
Yeah.
That's why when they say,
Oh,
rugby is so much harder than football.
No,
they don't have a false sense of
security like football players do.
Yeah,
you're,
you're jarring your melon like that.
That's not good.
Even if your skull is
protected from cracking,
it's a soft innards that are the issue.
Just the impact alone.
That's a,
it's a weird sort of a thing though,
to tell,
to tell people that you would be safer.
You know the,
you would actually be safer if
you had a leather helmet on.
People don't want to
hear that kind of shit.
That's that kind of weird logic.
Like it would actually be
better if drugs were legal.
People wouldn't do drugs.
Like what the fuck he saying
fall drugs were legal.
I mean less,
right.
I've never had more fun driving a car.
Then when I was 16 and didn't have a
license and my brother's girlfriend was
going to let me drive a car illegally.
Yeah,
and now I wish I had that
thrill of sitting in traffic.
I shouldn't be doing this.
Do you remember the thrill of
just piloting the car at all?
Just moving it around and
it's turning and stopping.
It was so fun.
When it was illegal,
it was the most fun.
I don't have a license.
I'm driving illegally.
We just,
we realized by US stepmothers Toyota
Corolla wagon would turn on with a butter
knife.
Like the key.
You didn't even need a key go out of
town and we'd be driving all over butter
nation.
Yeah.
Just anything.
You leave it in,
it would turn.
Fuck.
Did someone figure that out?
What?
My brother was trying to figure out how
to hot wire a car realized they didn't
need
to.
Well that was the thing that
would break off on some cars.
They would break off the part where the
key goes in and just stick a screwdriver
in and just turn it off.
Like instantly.
Took like five seconds.
Didn't even have to do that.
It was some shit designs of cars.
I guess some of them just fucking just
now the push button ones and now it's
probably a pain in the deck.
We want to really try to,
I get a coach button,
one push button.
Oh,
it's beautiful.
You keep the keys in your pocket.
Just get in there.
You don't have to think about shit if
you live in Bisbee and keep the key right
in the car.
I probably shouldn't have said that.
Random illegal aliens
sneaking across the border.
Yeah.
By your fluorescent [inaudible] insurance.
There you go.
Yeah.
Fuck him.
Fuck,
I'm looking at you.
You don't give a shit.
That's gangster.
Have you heard of Gungeon before?
Jets?
It's a calculated risk again,
dungeon gushing.
Gushing is no,
is that that fat Korean guy?
No.
It's [inaudible] styles.
When you take a dead lady
and you and your friend,
you got stuck on her pussy and the
other guy jumped on her stomach.
She off the phone.
Alright to shut the fuck up.
Go to the hospital.
But I do remember on that
man shall using w w w gets,
everything's censored,
but they had no idea.
All the new Cleveland,
Cleveland Steamer and so we'd throw all
those in because they have no idea what
a dirty Sanchez is.
So it is to any vulgarity,
dirty sand.
Some girl told me that.
Yeah,
well yeah,
Molly did it last night.
I think it was her story.
I not allowed to say that anymore.
How does it,
you can,
can you say Cleveland Steamer on yeah,
TV.
But as long as you just keep
making up through memes,
new ways,
new obscenities,
you can just keep saying stuff
because they'll never know.
Pointing that the,
the customer thing has been worked out
yet it's just that alone deflates all
your faith in humanity.
Just the idea that you've created the,
you've made a word dirty
and now you can't say it
now it's over forever and you
never get those words back cut.
Like never makes it just like,
you know,
seeing on whatever desperate housewives
or at any kind of show of cheese,
a condom.
Dora the explorer is the idea that
if it were completely okay to say it,
then we kind of lose.
Cause then you don't have any expletive
when you really want to deliver a
thought,
you're a fucking cunt.
And if it was an okay word to say,
then what are you going to say to make
someone upset when you want to hurt their
feelings?
Eh,
comma fucking dummy.
It's just as just say there is,
I don't,
I wouldn't miss it if
cutting lost it's impact.
I'd be fine with dummy or fuckface stupid,
stupid,
stupid fart.
That actually makes it easier cause then
then you'd have to go after them for
aesthetically you're,
you're an pleasing to the eye.
Yeah.
Well you wouldn't have,
and that's just their personality sucks.
Dick,
I was uh,
you're boring.
Like
you could never insult me more.
You're boring.
Oh,
that's my biggest fear.
You tapped into it there.
We shouldn't have said that either.
There was a dude once,
I'll never forget this.
I was watching like one of those Jenny
Jones shows and there was a girl and she
was out with her mother and her mother
was upset because the girl was dressed
and trashy and uh,
this,
uh,
the girl was like,
I don't give a fuck.
Like I beat whatever neon mother beep.
Say,
ah,
you know,
I know I look good.
And some guy got up and he goes,
the problem is all about your personality.
He goes,
if you have some Pazazz,
maybe you would pull that off,
but your personality sucks
and then make you look nasty.
Never forget him saying
that your personality sucks
and that may you look nasty
and the place just fell out because it's
like black people of a certain way of
saying things and they say things
and they know how to phrase it,
that they know at the end of
that sense everyone around them.
Oh Shit.
Because when he did it,
it was like,
it was like an actor.
Like he was in a movie,
like he had the perfect line,
he practice it for weeks because your
personality sucks and that may you look
nasty.
And when he said NASA,
he knew it was coming.
He knew it was coming.
Everybody behind him,
the whole crowd just went nuts.
And that girl was like,
damn,
that motherfucker just dressed
me down and called me out.
It was beautiful.
I played my first black
room the other day,
I'll,
it was a casino and uh,
it was,
uh,
I was the only white comic and I thought
it was going to be like a regular black
guy,
but it was a,
a Bingo and a slot place.
And so it was just like 60 year olds.
And up for the most part in like in
those little crickets or whatever,
the little wheelchairs and I go,
you know,
I'm a dirty fucking comic.
And she's like,
ah.
The MC was like,
don't worry.
You know,
who cares?
They love dirty material.
I'm like in the whole thing got
broadcast throughout the whole casino.
So everyone that casino and so I,
I,
the first person comes up and she's like,
you know,
like taking questions like,
have you ever met,
you know,
will Smith or something like that.
And they're just talking about it.
And then they're like,
oh,
and here's Brian Red band.
I come out and start talking to
doing pussy jokes and calm jokes.
And Man,
that was the most horrible fucking
set I've ever done in my lap at all.
There was,
there was little pockets where you could
tell there was like a one or two people
that were like getting it,
you know.
Then most of the people at
least enjoying the discomfort,
much more likely that the
staff told me they love it.
They said they were
cracking their ass off,
but that was probably because they were
laughing at me having to do all this in
front of it.
But yeah.
How did the old people,
did anybody yell at you?
No.
No one,
no one.
Actually no one just said anything.
The one,
one of the ladies and the crickets or
whatever they call it did leave and uh,
I don't know where she went.
Me and Becker played a bus
once in our early days,
in the early nineties in Minnesota,
there was a bus that would
people from Minneapolis
to the Indian casino,
like an hour and a half away
and they hire a comedian.
Did you just walk up and down
the aisle with a cordless mic?
No,
we dared each other.
We were both going to deal at one time
and I was up first and we go and the bus,
we see the people getting
on and they're elderly,
not just old,
they're elderly.
And I'm like,
I have,
even if I did clean material,
it has no reference to them.
They don't,
wouldn't even understand what Columbia
House record and tape club is like.
So,
so I go,
you have to do this.
I can't do this,
and I'm going to sheer panic.
I like flop sweats.
Just thinking about watching
them go on the bus and he's like,
no,
you're going first.
Becker's of ball buster notes.
You good luck buddy.
Get on.
And they'd give me the
mic and I look at Becker,
he's sitting in the stairwell
of the bus and I go,
all right,
I'm stealing your act.
Here I go,
count.
I'll give you a dollar for every
one of the jokes of yours at use.
And I did Becker's act.
I used to sell doorbells door
to door or ring the doorbell.
They answered the door.
I go out next towels.
Fitzsimmons
you got a Gig once while
we were hired by a company,
they wanted comedians just walk around
this aquarium and make funny things and
talk to people and be funny like,
and we're like,
well,
what's the parameters?
Like what should we do?
Like,
well,
you know,
just be funny.
Go around and be funny.
So,
uh,
Greg,
this was in Greg's young,
angry days.
No,
they still,
they're still here.
I did his podcast a few weeks ago and he
was about to get into a fist fight with
the owner of the place
he rents his studio from.
They actually coming in and I'm like,
hi.
And he's like,
fuck you.
Yeah,
you would've fucking go,
I'll fucking grand walks
right past me and goes,
hey,
like he didn't even recognize me.
He's just boiling mad like you don't see,
wow,
that's crazy sauce.
But anyway,
back to his earlier I angry days,
he,
uh,
he
just,
there was like,
it was the opening of this
aquarium or opening of the exhibit,
I guess.
And so they had like food out there and
people were walking around and plates
and Greg would just walk up to people
and take food off their plates and eat it
right in front of them.
All right.
That was what he thought was funny.
He's so nice.
He's a great guy.
Look,
he just tries.
So it was trying to be funny.
He's trying to push the envelope.
I was trying to get a guy to go,
what the fuck,
man,
I want to do it.
But that he did it to this guy
and this guy was like so defeated.
The guys calls years,
you're an asshole,
and he did it like that.
You're,
you're,
you're an asshole.
I just walked away and I go,
hey man,
I go,
you can't be just taking food from people
is he ended up trying to joke around.
I thought it would be fun to joke around.
Is he in a bondage?
Does he like to be spanked and titans?
That's doctrine.
Doug.
It's in a ball gags and shit
saying I'm into it.
That is not me.
And then he told me that one time.
He said,
I was joking,
man.
He didn't know I was joking.
I'm like,
dude,
no you aren't.
They like,
that's total magic ball gags
and sharing diapers and stuff.
Well maybe I draw the line.
I'm into that stuff too,
but I draw the line at diapers.
Yeah,
that seems a little silly.
That seems unnecessary to try brand.
Trust me,
man.
Trust me.
It's great.
Hey everybody,
I'm wearing it.
Dunkin is another place in the
spectrum that you wouldn't have known,
known existed if it wasn't for Dunkin.
You know,
you wouldn't have known as a Duncan
Trussell out there fucking love Dunkin.
You know,
he just had a cancer surgery.
Oh,
that's right.
How did that go?
He said he feels better
than he's ever felt before.
He goes,
he goes,
turns out having cancer
makes you feel like shit.
They cut the cancer out
and now he feels great.
He had one of his uh,
nuts removed.
Now is it okay if somebody told me was
the biggest job most giant loads has ever
had in his life?
Said his dick is hard.
Like,
like,
like high school style.
Boners it was like is apparently his
whole body was fucked because one of his
balls had shut down and
it was going funky on him.
It was crazy.
Yeah.
Just went through a ball ball thing
right when that happens I'll thing,
yeah.
I did this crazy flight to get diamond
status and I didn't know if was flight
related.
I flew from Tucson to
Johannesburg to Amsterdam,
to Vegas,
back home through Salt Lake and uh,
Justin just to get
23,000 miles in 72 hours.
How many balls?
But on the last flight,
I just started getting this fucking
wicked ball pain in my left nut.
And then like I lasted like two by
the second day if I could get it,
whereas,
okay.
Uh,
but if I got up to stand up and would
just almost floor me like tears in my eyes
just as like,
like someone like twisting the
fucking back that you know,
that back cord on your neck
and shit.
And I,
so I,
I don't,
I don't go to doctors
unless it's necessary,
but I did tweet about it.
Like that's how I get my medical advice.
Go on Twitter and go,
hey,
my ball really hurts.
She pull your groin.
So I got,
uh,
the,
the doctor that's always on ONA.
Dr Oz.
Yeah.
Wait,
no,
no.
Steve.
Dr Steve.
Yeah.
Punk doctor Oz.
So he walked me through his,
he said,
but it's nice and open.
It's almost definitely this.
And so I had a friend who brought over
some antibiotics that had been sitting in
their cupboard.
So what did he say?
It was almost,
it's,
I forget epidemic.
It's,
it begins with an e and it ends with the,
it never went to a doctor to doctor,
doctor,
Doctor Steve and found a lady in town
that had some stashed antibiotics and I
said I didn't take the full run.
We have
to do that.
She didn't get to cause aids.
You get a car super eight.
Do you know the whole deal?
You know you're not dumb,
you know the whole deal behind that.
Right?
Like the antibiotics,
the reason why you have
to take the full dose.
Yeah.
He creates stronger strains of bacteria.
So the point where they can't be treated,
that's where mercy comes from.
It's in my balls and I
don't really fuck anymore.
So I'd figure it's safe you say that,
but it could get out.
They can creep out of the underwear
in the middle of the night,
crawl down near your ankles and the
fucking jump free when the close to the
ground you're walking through tall grass.
Like it's time to make God move.
It's like a heartburn and come jump off
and then they jump on a baby living on
my jock strap.
Cause I said well make sure you
were at something supportive.
I was wearing a jock strap.
I'm still wearing it.
Haven't washed this is two
and a half weeks later.
But when it was in full bloom
like I couldn't push a Piss,
I'd piss.
But when it gets to the end part,
so yeah,
I am wearing a filthy to this day.
Yeah.
Why in this chair?
Why?
Why to keep my balls close to,
but I'm scared.
You just schedule it ball pain yet.
Yeah.
So badly.
Do they hang back?
Getting keyless?
Some underwear.
Just one science too tight
and I did that but I still,
I'm wearing the jock jock strap
and you don't wash this thing.
You just keep what happened?
Cause I didn't want to beat
without it for a laundry cycle.
You need to go to a doctor.
It's like the site.
My teddy bear now you need to go again.
It's like my pig pen blanket
that I won't give up.
It's your [inaudible].
Oh No.
Maybe you should just
buy more of them though.
Like who's that guy and I should,
I should do a lot of things.
I should make another
fucking McAfee Rogan podcast.
I've been busy.
I've been dealing with
fucking legal briefs.
Yeah.
It this because,
well,
you can't say I'll talk,
but after,
yeah,
we'll have to discuss this because the
whole thing is pretty fucking lick.
It is wicked fucking funny.
Do you,
you're not involved,
you don't do anymore that,
uh,
trolling for pedophiles.
Should they use no baiting.org?
No,
but it's mentioned in the legal brief.
Is it really?
I'll show you.
Oh,
this is like a standard
characteristics of Mr. Standoff.
The end.
I mean,
as long as you can talk about it on stage,
it's so worth it.
Whatever you have to pay.
I'll this footage that we,
that we need to get released,
it's fucking complete.
Chris Hansen caught on tape.
Wow.
That's hilarious.
That is hilarious.
That's funny how,
okay.
We can
do something you had planned.
I have to piss really,
really bad.
Okay.
You go ahead and Piss.
Really,
really go to a break.
We're going to talk about school
shootings are going to cheer everybody up.
Go down a first door
on the right hand side.
So do you know?
Uh Huh.
No,
it's just like a skull.
There's,
there's these tests to do.
You like Mtma Molly,
you could test the purity of
it and I forget what it was.
It was like,
you know,
if it turns blue,
it's pretty good.
You know,
it's pretty pure turns purple.
It's amazing.
If it starts smoking,
it's like almost a hundred percent pure.
MTMA.
So the stuff I did last night was smoking
and like this rich billionaire guy,
a guy who parties like every day,
he,
he's just like,
come to my mentioned later if you want to,
we have a party every night.
Like it's crazy.
But uh,
hold on.
Slow down.
You shitty storyteller.
Who is this rich billionaire?
Where are you when you're meeting
this guy through another person?
Through a secret secret person.
Okay.
So secret person knows rich billionaire
who likes to party somehow or another
get secret person,
some MDM,
but it's just a hundred percent pure,
100% pure.
Is that the stuff that
gives you no headaches?
Is that right?
It's pretty much ecstasy with just,
it's just pure ecstasy
as nothing else in it.
So you take this stuff so it takes the
stuff and immediately I had to like,
like just close my eyes
fall to the ground.
Like every single pour my body
felt like there was just like,
or like cum coming out of
every single hole of my body.
Fucking amazing.
Really?
Yeah.
How much did you take?
How many pills?
Uh,
to uh,
to two,
each
problem with ecstasy.
Like it's the same thing.
The problem that exists
with medical marijuana,
it's like your dosage.
Like who the fuck knows
what your dosages are?
Like if you buy a cookie,
a medical marijuana cookie,
you're really taking it crazy.
Giant risk.
You really have no idea.
The way red band described it
is he has some kind of test.
Who knows what scientist
gave them the information.
But if you,
you apply this whatever to the ecstasy,
if it turns blue and telling a
story did while you were paying.
Yeah,
I was just telling us that.
that's scientific as fuck.
That's like a mood.
Right?
But it's crazy cause I got to,
I thought that your show is at
a different theater last night.
So I was like,
oh,
it's at the pantageous theater.
So I got the hotel right
across the street from it,
and of course it was the wrong theater,
but the,
it was just half awesome
how that worked out there.
Like,
uh,
do you want a king size bed?
And I'm like,
yeah,
sure.
King size bed.
And they're like,
oh,
you're here for business or pleasure.
I'm like,
Oh man,
we've got to show across the
street and stuff like that.
She goes,
Oh,
well let me upgrade you
from when you were tanning.
He goes,
I'm a comic.
And she goes,
let me upgrade you.
Yeah.
And so we got like the pimps
repeating like the puff daddy sweet.
Yeah.
You're told us this already.
Rapper sweet.
Yeah.
But I was off the air and I just,
okay,
sorry.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah.
That's funny that you thought
it was the wrong place.
You're so fucked up.
Like learn what?
Theater that the name,
it's a different name,
right?
One starts with,
it starts with a w,
I don't know because it's been on my
website and I'll fucking six [inaudible]
and love by Ricky Lee Jones
and that's where chuck,
he was sitting behind us down
at the pantageous Chucky.
Apparently her voice is shot in.
She has something called more Jaylin's.
Do you know what,
hang on,
let me get a pen.
Is it,
is it terminal?
No,
God,
I need my death.
Pug.
Got To get my dental picks ready for 2013
Morgellons is what they think
is a crazy person's disease.
They don't know what the fuck this is,
but apparently it's fibers that are
embedded in people's skin and you can pull
them out and not only
can you pull them out,
but somehow or another the related to
nanotechnology and they actually vibrate
with music like eight out of 10
tell Jesse Ventura looked into this.
A lot of people looked into this.
It sounds crazy,
but this actually can be,
there's fibers that react to music.
[inaudible] have gone.
We'll sit by applying and those fibers
in her arm as a former governor,
loud to just walk into the CIA and go
through your files are maybe she'll,
why can't I go to area 51 pull,
pull up pictures,
more jelly beans.
It's a skin disorder.
And these people that get these horrible
rashes on their skin and the more
Jelena and more jealous disease.
Well Joni Mitchell has it and uh,
some baseball was some famous
baseball player has it.
And if you look at images it's like,
do people have pictures of this shit?
It's really strange.
It's um,
they're these tiny
fibers and these people,
they grow up,
they have like scabs on their skin
and these fibers grow their scabs.
You see that shit?
Well there's doctors that have like,
you know,
I mean they've done tests on these things.
They don't know what the fuck they are
and they think that it's related to
nanotechnology and nano
fibers and clothing.
All of these different things that they
can self assemble somehow when under the
right circumstances
they can self assemble.
And when they do that,
the problem is these things are moving.
And dividing and growing
inside someone's skin.
I hate when you're smart.
That's not smart.
This is repeating shit.
That's smart people.
I know.
That's,
I hate that you remember all that shit.
I read a book about something smart.
It's gone.
As soon as I shut the book,
my fucking head is completely empty again.
I find that a documentaries
for whatever reason,
I can remember things more
from documentaries and
exactly and I've always used
that argument about
people who have fucking,
oh well yeah.
What pickup a book.
Every now and then.
I don't remember it visual,
you know,
I see something on TV.
It sticks in my head more.
I had some more engaging medium.
It's like what I was talking about last
night when people talk to you about game
of Thrones,
like,
oh,
you should read the book or
you should read the book.
There's so much better and like
how the fuck could it be better?
I'm looking at naked people and dragons.
How could it be better if I'm reading
your telling me that's better.
You're full of shit.
Oh Shit.
It's not as engaging.
I do.
I do find it,
reading helps my creative process
because it forces you to imagine.
And so it's better for writing.
If I read something I thoroughly agree.
What's the fucking great
documentary guy of hers arm?
No,
no,
he's a British guy.
Uh,
did the
uh,
the eight,
the age of fuck.
Okay.
Campbell.
Joseph Campbell.
Are you listening?
Text me?
Yeah.
No,
he gets it about the age of self.
The uh,
that was a three part series.
Fuck.
Oh I see Chris something,
Eh,
nevermind.
Age of self.
Um,
century of self.
Century of self.
BBC.
Yeah.
What's his name?
Fucking brilliant
to hold on a second.
I'll find out.
It's a,
was it a BBC show?
Yeah.
No,
he's a century of self BBC.
Is that his name?
What?
No,
no.
Adam.
Curtis.
Yeah,
that's it.
I'm Curtis.
Adam Curtis.
Okay.
That guy puts out some really good shit.
Does he?
Yeah,
there's so many guys out there and
now putting out some really good shit.
This is like really,
really interesting times.
You know,
between like,
like,
like Neil degrasse Tyson is like
the first like mainstream celebrity,
New Scientist.
And it's cool cause he's black.
He's black and he's funny.
You know he's black.
He's funny,
he's right,
relaxed.
And he asked to have an earpiece to say,
oh,
he's fucking,
he's a real,
he's a real fucking super genius.
He's cool as shit,
man.
That guy's bad ass.
And again,
Adam Curtis tags to Bam,
boom.
Perfection.
Yeah.
Say Hey,
Sasha had texted me something.
Oh houseman.
He doesn't really text that much.
It's not really,
I've just always been my
manager against your manager.
Your manager wins and that's her.
But Google beat your managers.
So that's what people,
you try to put red ban against Charlie.
I'll put valve
lay money on that as far as,
yeah.
Will you bread lay money on Jaylee.
Hi Guys,
this is over calling
back to our last podcast,
doing what?
Doing what?
Well,
whatever I was talking about and you said,
oh fucking no is no way.
He's good as red band.
Wait a minute.
You think your podcast guy,
whatever the fuck you guys is as good
as this motherfucker all around who are
managing podcasting sounds and that's,
that's a slave.
You,
you,
you have a slave.
Brian's not slave.
He's a specialist.
Oh,
this guy.
He's a podcast masters slash
tech wizard slash silly bitch.
He does.
So he's actually entertaining on the show.
He helps us show out.
You guys you got can
suck at these no ways.
No.
Alright guys.
Not as good.
No way you guys.
Not as good as red bull.
Kind of a little bit of 70,000 Twitter
followers for a reason because he's
beautiful.
Look at him yet.
He is awesome.
Couldn't do without that motherfucker.
Don't you tell me your
guy's as good as him.
Oh,
you guys are damn slave.
You go out.
My Guy,
my guy couldn't open the show.
You guys washing your car.
You guys out there.
I get hate mail from your toilet.
Get a hate mails,
guys.
Specialist.
He's an artist.
It's disrespectful to you right now.
I feel very disrespectful.
I just want you to him
to bet you started it.
I was not ever said that.
He,
well listen,
we'll,
we'll give all the money
though the homeless.
No,
no stars or something,
Huh?
Okay.
We'll get all of the money to Brian.
Brian,
Brian can do comedy.
They only,
yeah.
My problem with my tour
manager is everyone hates,
he addresses goofy like me.
When we go on the road,
we,
we went and bought me and junior
stop gutting Carlos Valencia,
we and Bingo and Charlie all on the road.
We stopped.
We saw pimp,
uh,
like,
original kings of comedy suit store.
I went in and we bought all
everybody including Bingo,
big long shoulders and everything.
Shoulders.
Yeah,
we,
we all got,
we all got white except for Jr.
He's the only,
cause they're all built for fat people.
So the rest of us are small.
So we had to get white with different,
like we,
I had a,
uh,
pink and Charlie got black
and Carlos got purple,
like juniors,
like six foot something.
He looks just like the Indian from
one flew over the cuckoo's nest.
Looks like a retarded Mitch Hedberg,
like a misshapen head.
Mitch Hedberg,
long,
long stringy hair.
And she got aqua blue.
Uh,
but Chaley like he'll dress like me
and these ridiculous leisure suits,
but somehow people take them seriously.
And He,
I get hate mail from him.
Just going up to introduce the show.
Welcome to the show.
Turn off your cell phones.
We have a great show for
you tonight and here's it.
And someone emailed me and that first
guy with the fucking weird mustaches,
he fucking sucked like
he introduced the show.
But people know when someone's socks,
even when they're just introducing Sunday.
Okay,
you got can't fuck with them.
This guy gets standing
ovations when he goes on stage.
How dare you?
That's pit your slave up
against my master craftsmen.
Oh No,
my guys,
the fucking he can play.
I can play any base in the gameplay,
in a fucking band.
Stupid.
Go play.
He can do that too.
That there you play and he's in a band.
My Song,
I wrote those garden bumps.
It's been remade five times.
Hade it's almost as big as day.
That's good for him,
man.
He's delivering newspapers to look guys,
you've got a slave.
You take it a slave and you putting
them up against the specialist.
That's ridiculous.
Barden read Ben's legit.
How dare you sir.
How dare you?
He's mad.
Doug's just mad at me.
He treats his guy like a slave.
He's women live under,
I'm just promoting my guys.
The Guy Out,
he sends the guy out to go fucking
take gum off his tires and shit.
Hey death squad.
I hope that uh,
at junior stop cut has 50,000
fucking Twitter followers by now.
Well,
I don't even even think.
I'm glad you heard about that organically.
Totally organically.
Everybody was talking about it.
Apparently he's a,
he fucking killed at the comedy store.
A lot of people saying is this big guy.
He's got crazy hair,
I guess like Hedberg but
stringy Indian version.
I just started following him on Twitter.
I advise you to do the same.
We're only at 1,134 fucking followers.
I think by the end of this show we
can at least get them up to 2000.
I'm not asking for a crazy amount
and that's a reasonable request,
ladies and gentlemen,
because it goes,
follow him.
It's junior stopcock,
s t o p k and uh,
the fucking Dude loves funny pks.
Stop like stop sign and k a repeated what
you did earlier and you didn't add the
a earlier.
And then I asked you if there
was an a and you said yeah.
And then I did the same
fucking thing cause I'm,
see that's what I'm good at.
I'm good at repeating shit.
That's stupid.
It's a fucking Roos,
ladies and gentlemen.
But um,
this is a picture of junior sub can his
Twitter following and he's smoking a
cigarette and his hair is long and pulled
behind his ears to shitty choices in
life.
He didn't really has no choice
what to do with his hair.
You know,
you see his hair and you go,
that's just going to lay
like that no matter what,
unless you got a giant crazy perm.
Unless he got some like,
like Eddie Bravo spiky thing going on.
Maybe you could do that.
Do you know possum man?
No,
but he looks,
he looks kind of like possum.
And I have for you a
hardcore Hedberg fans.
What is possible possum mal junior stop.
Go right there as junior.
Yeah.
Well that's a face and a half right there.
Sign.
Holy Shit.
Is he parked Korean?
The fuck is he parked
Korean or part Frisbee?
He's just straight up retarded.
It's great.
He is so fucking good.
Where'd you pick him up?
Chicago.
Yeah.
Is there,
did you work for Ritter ever now?
I'm one of the things I was saying,
I was,
I did this a bunch of
interviews yesterday because uh,
my new special just came out and I had
to do a bunch of these things and uh,
but one of the things I was saying
was that like a real network,
like,
like death squad.
Like we actually have a
network and it's not official,
but that,
you know,
it's not like written down in
a contract form or anything.
But what it is is there's a network of
people that are really funny and they're
all connected with each other.
And like if I tell you about
Duncan trussell's cause
Duncan Trussell hilarious.
If I say,
Hey,
go listen to bill Burr,
I'm not steering you wrong.
I'm telling you about like
really hilarious shit.
And that's what I heard about this junior.
Stop you kid.
I'm like,
Doug,
Stan hubs taking them
on the road with him.
He's gotta be funny.
And then it was like,
this guy's hilarious.
And then boom.
It's like everybody's
talking about them already.
Tells me about I'm Dunkin
tells me about him.
A couple of people tell me
about him and it's like,
I love that.
I love,
That that is a real network is that
comics are getting support from all these
other like like your green lighting gum.
You know what I mean?
Like you're like this kid's greenlit.
Put them on the road for his
first legitimate road trip.
So to watch with new eyes,
what you used to be so excited
about and you're so bored with,
I'm not bored with it.
No,
I'm saying that the,
just the minutia of him getting
a free drink at the bar.
Exactly.
That he did.
He bingo had to show him the how to use
a roller bag cause he didn't know how
the,
he couldn't figure out the button
part of it to make the handle go down.
He went to a military website to
learn how to fold clothes properly.
To put in.
Wow.
You know what,
can we play some of his shit online?
Yeah.
I've never found anything
where the audio is any good.
Does Brian know he's got
to youtube things open?
Do you got another youtube thing open?
Yeah,
he's good at listening to.
That was the original kicks.
Please cancel that.
That's killing up bandwidth son.
I see a lady reversed on me.
This sounds sad.
It's nothing good on youtube.
Well,
you know,
that was me until I put out my first CD.
I don't have anything good out there.
You know,
it's funny that we knew and I,
we never would really think of you.
You don't want to think of that somehow
or another were from a different era,
but we really are.
Fuck yeah,
we came up in the era of no Internet.
Yeah.
We had to send a VHS tape
to a club to get booked.
It's hard to really wrap my head sitting
here and there's this office that we're
renting out just to do the internet,
you know,
with uh,
Brian and our,
and uh,
you know,
and everybody attached is our
whole lives completely different.
Just because the engine is a gym.
This guy right here,
that's Jamie.
Jamie.
All right,
well you do go.
It's Brian and I,
and then you motioned to him.
I'm waiting [inaudible]
names so I don't call him.
I met like all the people that were
there in the beginning of this whole
craziness.
It's like,
it's all because of I need,
I need a backup.
Uh,
just for,
uh,
okay.
Uh,
what was the giggle?
Yeah.
The giggle was that,
that wasn't Hennigan that texted me,
so,
oh,
I can't put Hannigan against Sussman
anymore because I just assumed some guy
that has my number you can
put of going against us.
One,
because Hennigan would probably crack
under pressure and it's awesome.
Just got fucking antifreeze in his veins.
Trust.
Yeah,
but fertilizer as a reason
why you crossed some clients.
Brian works solely,
you know how many clients he's got?
One.
Really?
Yeah.
You got the same deal?
No,
he's got one other client.
Oh yeah.
It's like another guy who's a
director is pretty low maintenance,
but it's like,
it's three people all the time.
The agency.
All right,
beautiful.
Yeah.
They don't fuck around,
suspends the cleaner.
But he was fucking strong on the marriage
and he's wrong about a lot of shit too
though.
He told me not to have the
fleshlight sponsor the podcast.
Oh yeah.
He doesn't like me talking about this.
And that's by Brian talked
me into doing that Oslo DVD.
So what was wrong with the Oslo DVD?
Didn't like it.
It was fucking brand new material
that if I did the same material nine,
six months later,
even it would have been a fucking great.
Great.
Yeah.
Honestly that wasn't one
of my favorites of yours.
Oh,
I ate it.
It,
but uh,
you know,
and I worry sometimes when someone
puts out something that like,
man,
like maybe like they're losing
enthusiasm or the health's not good.
But then you came back with
before turning the gun on himself.
Holy Shit.
Was that good in my car,
listening,
clapping and laughing.
Long drive.
That's what we did.
When we listen to your fucking
Jamie Kilstein podcasts,
we were in,
in the van with junior and jumping
out of our fucking van seats,
like fucking unruly children.
Go to a special school.
Well,
you never even saw the Jamie kills team.
Delusion videotaped this kid.
Uh,
Brandon Aka the mischief maker on Youtube,
put out kills team.
Went on his podcast.
Yeah,
no,
I did see that on Youtube.
That was fucking crazy.
And that was sad.
There's two parts to it.
I don't know if you ever,
yeah,
I can't watch the rest of it.
It's just say it ran its course.
Yes.
It ran its course and he was talking
about it recently on a stage and he said
that he was on a news channel.
I mean the way he described the situation
was that he was on a news station and
that he was saying that rape is bad
and that he got all this hate from the
Internet.
I was like,
wow.
You talk about like painting Oban Fuck
is biased picture of what actually
happened.
You know,
the idea to me is going to,
this is going to drive me
crazy to the end of the time.
The,
one of the things I loved about Bill Burr,
there was a video of that I saw of Paul
Provenza show the green room and bill
burr was on there with 'em Lizz Winstead
and they were debating back and forth
about the whole Tracy Morgan thing.
And he's like,
what was this?
The best innography in the history of the
world is fucking guy remembers exactly
what he says after a whole hour set.
He could tell you exactly the word for
word what this guy said and the context
in which she said it,
get the fuck outta here.
You know?
And I was like,
thank you.
And then the other was in the green room.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And I so love that bill did that,
but the,
and the,
you know,
the,
the other thing that drives
me crazy about this whole,
uh,
like shit,
like the Tracy Morgan thing
and it relates to this,
is that everybody wants
to pretend that the,
the,
there's not an art form
and saying unbelievably
ridiculous shit that you don't
really mean.
Yeah,
it's a fucking art forum.
It's just like Nwa talking about shooting
cops and not really shooting cops.
Okay.
They used to be in a fucking
band where they did like disco.
Okay.
They're just,
this is the art form.
This is what they're trying to sell.
And with a guy like Tracy Morgan or
a guy like Brian Holtzman or dice,
you know,
had Holtzman on,
no,
we gotta we gotta locate him.
Apparently he's like a,
he's a meter maid or something.
But he was,
you said he was just out since the fucking
new town shooting talking about it at
the comedy store?
I didn't,
no,
I didn't say that.
You were saying he was like,
those kids went bad.
None of them.
That was Susan Smith.
He was talking to a woman who drowned.
I thought he was out doing,
I surely has banned him from the comedy
store after nine 11 for like a week.
Cause they knew he'd say the bad,
bad thing.
He was saying the bad,
bad things.
The Susan Smith thing was,
that was,
uh,
the woman who drowned her.
It wasn't?
No,
that was I,
I just,
I heard a half a,
Oh,
and I assumed when you said,
and he's up there on
stage and that he's a bad,
bad kids anyway.
I get assumed like people like
Lizz Winstead and a video.
Then that shit infuriates me.
The idea that you're going to pretend
that this is a statement of his opinions
and not a re who is the top.
She created the daily show.
It's a very intelligent woman.
She was her roots.
She just stand up.
She started out as a standing
standout Chelsea handler.
Where did she come from?
She was again,
she's a good comic man.
She was a very good comic
ever as a common well,
I knew her.
I knew her from the store,
you know,
I always respected her as a comic.
I think she'd be great
to get hammered with.
Yeah,
she's a bad ass bitch man.
She's a bad ass bitch.
He's religious and so's Lizz Winstead
she's legit to me and she's really
brilliant,
but she also like a lot
of brilliant people.
She's like incredibly like rigid and
stubborn and our ideas and this idea that,
you know,
I look,
there's a weird idea that if you're in
somehow or another making fun of anything
gay or somehow or another making fun of
anything that has to do with women that
you,
you somehow or another,
especially coming from the
point of view of a white male,
which is like we are
judged as always being the,
the,
the most fucked up in our beliefs,
the least deserving of any,
any slack,
you know,
the white male is like the
real problem in this society.
So when a white male is making fun of
gays or women and so all of a sudden you
are anti gang or a
sudden you're anti women,
it's completely ridiculous.
And I could see the fact that a lot
of people feel like there's some,
some back work to be made up when
it comes to like the gay community.
Like there's some like some damage that
means it needs to be covered because it
must absolutely suck to be gay and have
to deal with all these fucking people
that have an issue with what your
natural desires are with a bunch of other
people that are the same.
Natural desires are with
the same natural desires.
It's so stupid.
I so I can see this wanting
to protect and defend them,
but you can't pretend that someone just
fucking around is being serious because
then you ruin the whole point
you're making because their whole,
you point you're making,
you're making about real
people in real life.
When Tracy Morgan is like,
my son was gay,
I stabbed that little Nigga.
He's not being serious.
You're confusing,
uh,
an art form with real life,
with the real statements of real life.
He is a serious in the fact that
his child would be a nigger.
I mean,
technically he doesn't use the art.
It's,
it don't you understand?
Well,
maybe he's from Boston.
Uh,
the uh,
the,
I know I said,
Nigga,
the idea that a comic would,
you know,
would step up and try to say like a guy
joking around with hecklers about rape
is supporting rape culture.
I know.
That's,
yeah.
Damn God.
Yeah.
They're stuck.
Not make me fucking boil.
Boil with chimpanzee rage.
Just fucking wild dick biting rate.
That's the real rage.
Not Human rage.
You have a lot less rage.
I said watching you last night.
I go,
Joe has like this whole
human aspect to them now.
I think it might've been
when you uttered the word.
Well now I'm a father and you didn't like
go like normally a comics has now I'm
a father.
You Go,
oh,
I never want to hear you again,
right?
Yeah.
Louis C K is that made it okay
to not go down that her babies
are like little drug people.
I would've never done that road anyway.
No.
I always felt like there
was that for a minute.
I wasn't afraid of you
just seemed like nicer.
I'm always been nice,
man.
I just look,
I've developed in a very fucked up way.
You know,
if you,
you look,
if I look back in my own life,
in my own,
the time when I was in high school,
like the most important time,
all I was doing was fighting like
in my entire high school life,
my entire,
like all throughout my twenties
and into like 22 years old,
their early twenties all
I did was martial arts.
It's all I did.
So I was just wired for this
like really crazy reality.
And it took a long time
for me to like let that go.
It took a long time to like
really come off of def con for,
you know,
let's bring it to three.
Well yeah,
I could never do that
because I physically,
I'm not,
there's no amount of
training in the world,
but I would try to get smarter and
learn a lot of things so I could repeat
things or like,
you're in fucking,
but I can't do it anymore.
Now I read a book,
it's fucking gone.
You got to get you some Alpha brain.
Get him a block,
Jamie for
that fucking I'm up in it or whatever
you're promoting came up in it on it.
This is the same thing.
Alpha brain is from on it.
Okay.
Does it work with good?
Yeah.
It has a battle battle is my dick in my
brain are having a battle for who can be
the tortoise in the race.
Who can
just take 20 of them all together.
One take home with me the
first time I did your podcast.
We fuck it.
Promoted your flashlight.
I like,
I'm going home with one of these.
Nope.
No.
Joe Rogan.
Nope.
Nope,
nope.
Nothing in my fucking stock.
Cole.
I said,
if you just reminded me,
I have a box of them.
I'm bringing,
listen,
listen.
If if,
if it's anything like Bingos Vagina,
the fleshlight,
we'll just sit there and grow
hair because it's unused.
Oh.
Have you completely
given up on intercourse?
Yeah,
pretty much.
Unless we're doing a lot of drugs
will drive still horny in me.
Yeah.
It was like just scratchy,
horny.
No.
Just like,
oh,
I'm only,
I feel urge so I might
as well capitalize while like,
and then,
yeah,
it's seconds and it's over.
We try to fuck once in Oregon.
I remember it was so
like stupid and pathetic.
We just burst in a fucking
laughed or enrolled over like,
all right,
this is ride this out.
Wow,
that's amazing.
But again,
if I,
if you talk to a younger me and said,
yeah,
I remember you saying it other day,
I don't want to fuck
anymore is the day I'm dead.
That's me.
I don't like,
I don't know that in my thirties.
I like,
uh,
you know,
it's,
it was then,
it was still kind of fun.
If someone had wanted to fuck you on the
road and they're hot and it was quick
and easy,
you should go to a book that was
more about ego than actual right.
Worse it,
the road road pussy
was like keeping score.
It's like,
yes,
successful showing pictures.
I [inaudible] see what
happens off the podcast.
I didn't say about it last night.
I met from another 10 other
age era before cell phones.
There's a drawing on his phone.
Yeah,
I know.
I know what he's talking about.
So I go,
look,
at the end of the day,
it's like,
it's not an essential value.
You don't need to fuck.
And a lot of it is absolutely pointless.
I enjoy a lot of it is winning.
It's a fucking,
yeah,
it's a sense of score thing.
Sure.
And it's also like a reinforcement.
Knowing the people that find you
attractive and still want to fuck you.
And when you meet drugs on the road,
I love you.
Hey,
you will get you,
you want to smoke a joint?
I go,
I don't smoke.
But the day people stop asking.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
The day people stop wanting to fuck you.
That's sad.
That's sad thing.
We're milfs are dropping
hints when we don't,
you know,
have to stay here.
We could get outta here.
I mean,
I'm just saying,
the worst is when chicks that you
would never fucking a million years,
but they're your age,
so you should be fucking them.
And you're like,
oh,
I feel really bad that I just realized
that I should be fucking someone like
you.
Have you ever been in real life when
you're old girlfriends and she's like 45
now.
Oh,
it's terrible.
It's the fucking worst that have
lived in normal Massachusetts life.
Then the lunch lady down
this about fucking lunch,
lady shoveling snow makes
you age three times as fast
if you're asking him.
Forced.
I got married when I was 20 years
old to a girl I knew for two weeks.
That was my secretary and fraud,
telemarketing and we,
it was a drunk and Goof Vegas,
you know,
hey,
let's go get married.
And so now I just got divorced finally,
cause I know it's on paper out there.
I should have to pay or anything.
No,
no,
she,
she's,
I think Mary do another guy.
She was a psychotic.
She was like really a pathological liar.
Fucking crazy.
But she was like 12 years
older than me in bed.
No,
no,
no.
She was like evil crazy.
Oh No.
She might've shot up sandy hook.
But the point is,
she was 11 years older than me and
not really attractive at that point.
So now that means I was
married to a 57 year old woman.
Like if I saw her,
I like,
that's my wife.
I wish I could've seen her to go.
I'm married to her.
I remember when I first,
before I ever met you,
I saw photos of you.
I think that before I ever met you,
people were telling me you were really
funny and I saw a picture of you at the
Houston last stop and you had long melody.
Heck see hair long,
beautiful hair.
And I was like,
look at this asshole with his long hair.
You're telling me this guy's farming
town is Doug Stan hope guys.
Really funny.
It's a,
you said something once and I
repeated all the time on the podcast.
We had a conversation.
You were a little lit up or we're
talking on the phone and he said,
I could give up comedy but
I couldn't give up comics.
Yeah,
no,
I fucking say that sober too.
I Miss Comics so much.
It's just such an ease
about being around them.
That's why the fucking industry in
the green room was such a vulture.
You just fucking Leech off of.
Oh yeah.
That was 1,995 God,
this doesn't even look like you.
I bought that suit at a thrift store for
the finals of the San Francisco comedy
competition.
Even your fucking head.
That's my face.
That's weird.
That's like when you see
like Charlie's thrawn.
No,
not Shirley's.
Thrawn.
Who's the other chick?
Yeah.
Charlise thrawn in their ideas.
Sleeping beauty when they make a living.
She's 20 again.
Oh
yeah.
Just looking at pictures of dogs.
There you go.
Okay.
I get this album come.
Unfortunately Google support.
It was great.
I think the first time I saw you though,
was that the,
uh,
that little place?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
My mother was performing.
That was a little place
that was at sunset,
right?
Fine.
Yeah.
It was beside the place.
That was cool.
Yeah.
That Jay Davis ran.
I forget the name of that place.
Davis is a fucking Hoofer.
You talking about dude,
who puts in the hours?
He's,
he's a late age.
Josh de Denado.
If I go to a,
who actually started Largo and then when
I became cool fucking cool people took
it away from him.
Like let's go.
All right,
thanks for throwing all those
flyers on cars for three months.
We got it.
We got on to greener pastures,
son.
Yep.
Yeah.
That place,
that little small,
tiny place.
That was the first time.
That's where I met Rene,
my
latter wife,
the Nancy to my sin.
The wanted to my boot cows.
She uh,
I still like her.
She hasn't talked to me in years,
but she wanted a bad person.
She's had a couple of issues.
She'll on a bad person.
I liked her because she liked wheen.
I always thought when was
Weezer until like a week ago.
I love that Hash pipe song.
I thought it was weed.
Oh,
hang on.
Here's Yoko to sing.
Ween
spinal Bifida man.
Wow.
Is Yoko spinal meningitis can be done.
It's great.
Dentsu when we'd started the man show,
there's a club called the three two one
in Memphis and wean was playing the same
night I was playing and they did a wean
after party without weans knowledge.
So they had me go over and introduce
the band in front of ween and
fuck the host of the mad show Doug
Stanhope though Yo fucking knew Matt show
sucks or yelling at me and I'm
like I'm just here to introduce,
hey ladies and gentlemen,
welcome out ween and like one of the
band members came to the club afterwards
for this pseudo after party.
Renee was so shit phase.
She pissed the couch and went
into fucking rehab the next day.
That's my wean story.
Yeah,
that um,
that would be unfortunate.
The last thing we want to do is go on
stage in front of a bunch of people after
you just replaced some
people on another show.
The replacing people.
If we just had the Doug and Joe show
opens when it sucked anyway,
anywhere now with the just
in that amount of time,
which is 10 years,
I guess that is a lot of time.
Look if we wanted to do something well
we could do now is we could just produce
it ourselves.
Just release it entirely on the Internet.
Exactly.
Completely possible.
Well,
I'm out of my record contract
on I now I can do fucking DVDs.
Louis C K.
Oh really?
Oh fucking Louis Ck.
Hey fucking return a call.
Cont wow.
What's a matter you call it?
I'll tell you off the air.
He's kind of busy.
That guy.
Yeah,
he's too busy.
I think he started thinking
about what he does,
editing,
writing,
producing and performing in his own
show and writing an hour of new comedy.
Did I tell you?
Did I tell you what I
did the part for him?
No.
What I would,
I did the thing on Louis.
Uh,
he,
he called me and he said,
Hey,
do you do any acting?
And I said,
no,
I suck at it.
I was very open.
I suck at acting again,
just knowing that I'm glad the TV with
my face is not where I can see it in this
studio because that just,
just seeing me in monitor on the mantra,
I fucking,
I see my head frees up.
Oh,
I said,
I suck at it.
He goes,
yeah,
but would you want to,
uh,
and I said,
I'll try it.
I'm just telling you
upfront I stink at acting.
And so he,
uh,
we read through the part
via Skype and he said,
okay,
we read through it once,
do this different,
try this,
get familiar with the material and
we'll do this again in a couple of days.
And I said,
okay.
And then I'm walking around my backyard,
I'm doing the lines to my dogs to Bingo,
reading the,
just trying to get it fucking right.
And he didn't call back.
So then there's like two weeks
later and how that mother Fucker,
I told him I suck at acting and you don't
even have the decency to call me back
and say we went another direction.
But then I'm about to do stern.
I'm a play in New York,
so I'm going to do stern.
So my idea was I'm going to go on stern.
I have these lines memorized.
So what I'm gonna do is I'm going to
insinuate them verbatim into conversation
with stern.
So,
so months later when you've booked
someone else to play this part,
it's gonna look like you stole the
entire script from my Howard stern
appearance.
And then he called and said,
Oh,
I'm sorry I was busy.
I get you.
Get the part,
I want to do this stern thing.
Yeah,
no,
I think he's,
he's almost too busy.
It's like,
I love the fact that he's so inspirational
with is all the different shit that
he's doing.
But at a certain point
in time you're like,
look at the pace that he's putting.
Like,
okay,
I'm just like doing the math
and I'm not that good at math,
but when I do the math I go to,
there's just this,
this doesn't seem like
a lot of time for fun.
They're like,
it seems,
this seems like a crazy pace.
Yeah.
Did doing a show,
recording a show,
uh,
editing it,
producing it,
and then doing a whole
hour of standup every year.
Like wow.
Yeah,
no,
he,
he called me about something I,
that's why I'm saying,
Hey fucking Louis called me back or email
me back because I don't know what you
fucking check anymore.
But he called me about something and
I've been trying to follow up on,
oh,
okay.
I'm not like,
Hey,
I want to talk man.
Now that you're big and famous,
let's chat.
I'm not that guy,
which is a my house.
You don't need to go.
The guy that emails you from a different
email address every fucking time.
And I'm like,
I don't know which one
to contact you back at.
Oh,
that's funny.
Yeah,
isn't it fine?
The pressures of stardom
and then you also have the thing,
well maybe he's telling
me to fuck off again.
Just like I did the first
time when I get the part,
but he was busy.
I don't think it's that I get to,
fuck,
I got to get on the new
CD is so fucking ready.
I got to get something out.
Like what?
You're doing the material too long,
you know,
if you don't keep doing it,
you're going to forget
all the nuances of it.
When did you leave before
turning the gun on himself?
That's a year and a half ago,
but we taped it July of 10 I it is now,
wait,
oh 11.
Yeah,
July of [inaudible] 11 and
then it didn't get released.
It's released digitally
in March of this year.
But then showtime picked it up
so they could only do digital,
you know,
online audio release till showtime aired
it in August and then they had a 90 day
window before we could
sell the actual DVD,
which is,
you know,
a fucking eight track tape now.
Yeah,
I was excited when I saw it on showtime.
I didn't know you were doing it that way.
I thought you were just doing it as a CD.
I know.
Yeah.
I don't,
I don't like to see
myself but DVDs sell more.
What was your,
um,
what was your deal that you had,
you had some sort of a,
you were locked into a deal,
like a long term
runner had a four record.
Why the fuck did you sign that?
Cause a upfront money.
Oh
yeah,
you can.
I would never sign like a four or three.
I,
everything I've ever done is one.
It seemed like a,
that's a douchey movement.
Assign you to a four fucking,
that's what they let us out of your work.
Oh,
they let you out of it.
that's cool.
Yeah.
That's like years.
Everything is digital.
I know.
Yeah.
But again,
I'm,
I'm still backlogged.
This material,
I'm going to have to go back.
Like I,
I've done so much that I'm going to
have to relearn because I do have,
I have a fucking good chunk now.
Yeah.
Um,
I saw,
I saw everything that I saw.
I mean,
I only watched a certain amount because
it was trying to concentrate on my own
shit,
but everything I saw was completely new.
Oh yeah.
There's a lot of that shit's,
that'll be on the next one.
Like I had a backlog of other shit.
Good.
So how much do you have ready for the
night you have like do you do like an
hour,
an hour and 10
did last night I had a shaved down,
I tried to do 40 and I,
I evidently did 50,
but that was like cutting
out a whole lot of detail.
I think we both did the same.
I think I did 49 and I think Joey did 30.
And then honey honey did
like 20 is a long ass show.
But it was awesome.
Yeah.
That crowd man,
they're amazing.
They were like with us that squad,
we're going to have to uh,
cause cause the Stan hope sausage army
is like a revolutionary of fucking stand
compared to death squad.
So I think we might just
have to have a branch.
You missed what uh,
with uh,
Ben said then if you
didn't see honey honey.
Yeah.
Then they were,
they were in the middle of
playing and they played this,
first of all they played angel of death,
which is like one of my favorite songs.
And they do,
it's amazing.
And then he said,
uh,
it's so crazy that,
since we did the podcast,
we will go to these places and perform
and do these like really like deep
emotional songs.
Any here
I see,
I see almost one death squad
tee-shirt per show at my show.
Yeah.
All Day,
man.
That's cool.
They're out there.
Well,
it's,
you know,
we,
we talk about,
I don't know how it happened,
it sort of happened organically.
Uh,
I don't know how we got
this amazing following,
but they're like the nicest
fucking human beings.
The world.
They are like super enthusiastic.
They're super cooled,
they're everywhere.
It's really weird and it's growing.
And the crazy thing is you
get these likeminded people
that come to these shows.
That's one of the more interesting things
about it is these people that come to
these shows,
they're like really friendly
openminded people who are like,
and it all comes from the podcast,
all of it.
100% of it.
I mean,
a lot of them were friends
of my standup before,
but this movement all
comes from the podcast.
But when,
when you realize that kind of power,
when you get those people
together on an anonymous level,
I fucking love anonymous so much
where you can actually fucking change.
Yeah,
and not,
let's go to the polls or picking a thing.
No,
let's do something weird and funny.
That's fuck with it on a creative
level that is actually art.
Well the in,
but an anonymous case,
it's like you gotta be really careful
if like if you're a company and you're
doing something shady,
they'll take you down.
Oh yeah.
We'll go and find the to structure.
They'll figure out a way
to hack in your system.
That's why you have to do it creatively.
I'm an armchair
revolutionary at this point.
I'm,
yeah,
I at any point really,
well,
no,
I'm not getting a farm here.
Gas at the WTO riots.
It's not my thing.
I don't run quick.
I'm fucking,
I'm easily winded
but it,
but you can do funny shit where I've seen
what my fucking fan base will do when
that guy was stealing my
shit online and they just,
they decimated him.
Yeah.
There was a guy for folks
who don't know the story.
Somebody sent Troy home was his name,
h.
O.
L.
M.
E somebody put it up
by my message board when
Doug found out about it.
But there was some character that
was taking all of Doug's rants and,
and,
and bits and putting them on a
blog like verbatim,
like taking exact like transcripts of
cds or blog updates and then promoting it
on his Twitter.
Come read my tales of real life,
uh,
perversion and drugs.
And it said he's trying to like make
himself into some fun Thompson character.
No fucking worse.
Like a fucking halfass Tucker Max.
And that's a quarter of an ass because
that guy is the worst piece of shit and
I'm fucking world.
Oh,
do this desk squad fucking mountain.
No referendum.
Anytime you're in an airport or a
bookstore and you see a fucking Tucker Max
book,
take another book and put
it in front of this stack.
Cause they,
they always frontload his books and
just so no one ever sees the book in the
airport.
What?
Tucker Max.
He's just a,
you know,
he's a Joe Francis from
girls gone wild type of dude,
you don't have to do any research.
You know immediately he's that kind of
fuck that just gets off on people hating
him.
All you have to do nowadays to
be famous is to be easily hated.
That's what all those
reality shows are about.
They just put a dick on the reality.
Are you going to watch American chopper?
Do you want to watch
people weld for 30 minutes?
No,
but if someone's going to be
an asshole to someone else,
and that's creating this
influx of people who are like,
I want to be an asshole so I
can be famous of fucking Lou.
I want to be a fucking Paris Hilton card.
Dashi and asshole.
Anyway,
you don't have find
fascinating when people learn,
when they try that and then they learn.
And what I really saw that
was with Camille Grammar
who was Kelsey Grammer's ex
wife and it was,
you know,
she's on the real housewives of Beverly
Hills and one of the things like,
you know,
they would have each character go out
and say who they are and just like,
you know,
I'm finally stepping out
of my husband's shadow,
you know,
and for what?
For being a cunt.
And that's what she was for one season.
She was a client,
she was a ruthless con and the backlash,
the fucking and repercussion they'll
below back was so intense that she
completely switched it
up on the next season.
She's like,
I'm done with this.
I'm just going to,
I don't give a fuck what you do.
I'm a sweetie,
give you a hug.
I send you on your way.
She didn't want any more
negative attention anymore.
The first season all she was
doing was talking shit and this,
she was married to her husband and she
was like riding on motorcycles with other
guys,
like her friends that were
like struggling actors.
And I'm like looking at this
like this is this gusting
and we have to have people in the
industry that work on these shows.
Any fucking dirt.
You can email me anonymous anonymously
about the fucking reality shows and how
exactly they're staged.
They're all stays now.
I mean,
the one that they did at
the comedy store when,
uh,
you know,
Ari did a Dunkin,
God bless him,
quit his fucking job.
They wanted him to,
uh,
to be in on the reality
show at the comedy store.
And rather than be on television,
Dunkin quit his job
answering phones for real.
He's like done.
Dunkin has to be making a decent living.
He is now,
yeah,
it's really recent.
It's over the last year or so.
It's a crazy
this and that's again,
the podcast,
introducing people to his podcast
and his podcast taking off and yeah,
it's amazing.
He,
he makes the living now it's selling his
posters and tee shirts and then doing
gigs.
Right.
Fuck,
we got to get posters.
That's the need to reprint that one,
Doug,
that,
that's one of my favorite posts.
It's all made out of like heroin needles.
And drugs
default photo on Twitter.
I had that put original poster.
No,
that's an old one,
but we would love if you
got any copies of it.
I would love to get it to put
it up in here if you're not.
I haven't.
I have no,
I just have that one.
Do you use it?
Oh yeah,
it's my favorite place for
washboard jerking off on,
so I was thinking just take it if
you can get us a copy of it though,
man.
I would love to put it up in here
because already just gave me one of his
posters.
I'm going to have it framed and put up
in here and I know a lot of comics used
to do it,
but I like head shots but
no one has head shots anymore.
They don't exist anymore.
I want to do that for my house but get
a comics headshots and put them on the
wall like the old ones.
Yeah.
I got really old ones from the Warner
brothers days from 1999 I'll get you one
of those.
No,
no,
I have you.
Fuck.
Yeah.
I would love to get everybody's oldest
headshots that they have the most
embarrassing ones.
I don't know.
I don't have him anymore,
but I had some ones where it had a
leather jacket on like a tank top,
and I got some acids.
I looked sorry.
Really bad.
I have one of me standing in a swimming
pool in his suit up to my chest with a
wicked Billy Ray Cyrus mullet,
holding a glass of wine with sunglasses
on because I thought it's crazy.
Two years into the business,
you know,
here's the hack one that everybody tries
the standing in the boat with
a mugshot with your name on it.
Oh yeah.
Oh God.
I tried that one.
I tried.
I couldn't do it.
It was just so pathetic.
You know,
Louis C K is one that he
had for like 15 years,
was one of those pictures from
when he was like 16 or 17,
uh,
that you're getting a stripped
from sitting in a booth,
you po and you get a strip of
four pictures for 15 years.
He fucked.
I might be exaggerating,
but forever until he
was a fucking grown man.
He used that as his headshot.
Wow.
That's funny.
Yeah.
Oh,
headshots were funny
thing like Mike Donovan.
Do you remember Mike Diamond?
Did you know Mike Donovan at all
too common?
A name to say
really hilarious Boston comedian,
but one of the things he said it,
he goes,
any comics,
it's worth his fucking salt.
Doesn't have a head shot.
That's it.
They always say,
that's the guy that
ruins you as a open mic.
You Go,
oh,
I can be unprofessional to without an act.
He wanted you to be unprofessional.
He didn't give a fuck,
but he was hilarious.
I mean,
he was right in certain ways at which is
really be concentrating on is your act.
That's why Dane Cook,
uh,
the hatred of Dane Cook hurts so many
comics because they would a shoe my space
based solely on their
dislike for Dane Cook,
where social networking,
that's why comedy clubs
have comment cards,
is to get direct access to the audience.
But you,
you don't want to go on my space and
do a good thing for your career cause
that's so Dane Cook.
We'll fucking get past that Dane
Cook and look at how the thing works.
There are guys there is they do a shoe.
The uh,
the social media Bill Byrd didn't have
Twitter until we signed up for him for
them.
Cops are here cause that shit.
Audio issues.
Helicopters,
helicopter Bill Burr Bingo.
Right on time with the fucking
vodka and grapefruit juice.
Perfect.
But liquored up.
Yeah,
I am as well.
This is a,
I love having this studio though,
man.
This is fucking great.
Fucking so exciting to have our own space.
It was so disappointed
when I went to your house.
Have I said this before?
That's so normal.
No,
when you had it in your
house and it was like,
it was like boxes of clothes and shit.
Like you always go so far
out to make everything.
I thought you'd have this and you're
like set up and we're sitting on a couch
like public access TV.
Both trying to look into the
camera but talk to each other.
At this,
you know how to do it.
It took a while to figure
out how to do it right.
At first I figured out,
well,
let's just put like a little coffee
table and some microphones on it and a
couch.
That'd be comfortable,
but couches aren't,
they're comfortable.
It turns out no,
not to talk to each other.
No couches suck.
Office chairs are where it's at.
Like a good solid leather offers this,
this,
yeah.
This a oak table.
People liked wood.
Wood feels good.
Feels good to put your hands on it.
You did it the opposite of how I do it.
I would have the whole setup
and then not know how to do it.
Hello.
Well that's exactly how I would
do it if it wasn't for him.
That's why he's better than your guy.
I'm not talking about the electronics.
I'd have someone else do that.
I just wouldn't,
I,
I'd stutter and go.
Um,
I,
yeah,
this is the,
we did that at first.
Go back and if anybody wants to,
if you're a fan of this podcast and you
listen and go back and watch episode
one,
if you have any illusions
of how great we are at this,
if you can see the exact fucking
evolution of this sort of a thing for us,
we were terrible.
This is exactly what we
want to do at the house.
We got to,
you know,
small,
small time equipment,
but we tested it.
Sounds great.
And are the,
we have a thing between the dining room
and the kitchen is a table this shape.
Well listen,
I've got a great solution for you.
I know exactly what the way to do this.
How about this?
How about we'll pick up the equipment.
We'll,
we'll,
we'll order everything for you.
We'll have it installed in your house.
No,
we have the equipment.
We have the equipment to do it right.
We tested it.
We did a fake podcasts.
Absolutely.
Shit faced.
You have an account to upload it
so you have everything.
Yeah.
All I need to do is fucking
man up and get on a mic.
That's it.
Yeah.
So you're ready?
Oh,
what I was gonna say is there,
we'll set it up for you
and put you on desk squad.
Put you on,
on,
on Brian's network.
What?
We can do that too.
Well,
if you do that,
you're going to get more viewers for sure.
People are gonna know about it.
It'll be,
it'll be something and it'd be awesome.
And right now he's got Kevin Pereira on
who's fucking hilarious and you know,
and you and Kevin Prayer would be
amazing if you want to do it that way.
I don't be easy.
It would be easy to promote it.
Join in,
join us,
join us.
See,
I think of death squad as anonymous.
I don't know how it
actually works into this.
We'll look at this,
this,
this is how it works.
The way it works is I call
my fans a sausage army.
I call your fans death school.
It is going to have to fucking
succumb to your corporate takeover.
We're all the same.
It's all just saying the,
the,
the sea.
There's death squad,
which is
Brian and Joey and Ari and
Eddie Bravo and Tait Fletcher,
that his desk squad.
That was all of us that
has Dunkin does you?
You're included.
Anybody but death squad,
honey,
anybody comes in the pocket?
Anybody crash?
You're going to mention his name.
Powerful.
Bert Kreischer is
unquestionably desk squad.
Jamie Kilstein got thrown out.
Yeah,
he got thrown out.
He can make his way back,
but he's got to eat meat suck cause
something happened along the line.
Start at sausage army.
Jamie,
something happened along the line
and you're going to have to sit com.
We,
anyway,
Brian started a the desk squad.
Dot TV website and death squad podcasts
was sort of like an extension of branch
and then everyone has
their own little branches.
You know what I'm saying?
Like like Ari's Po got the skeptic tank.
That's a branch of the desk squad
and network and it's like we're all,
it's all the,
I mean whatever the word is,
a weird word.
It's a,
it's just like an approval
of the group of friends,
like to noise you make with your mouth.
That means all of us,
what we would all
and it's,
it's something that we'll come back
to haunt you in a court of law to ask,
well,
if you called this death squad and
you're claiming you're not a terrorist
organization,
digital niche,
I have death and so many of my fucking,
I'm going to be dead some days.
Your first I have death is a theme in all.
Almost all my cds,
I had a deadbeat hero die laughing
before turning the gun on himself.
I didn't even notice from Oslo.
That's why I didn't listen.
I have the title is the best
part of getting the great
title for a CD and that's
why that one is a shitty title
cause I knew it was a shitty DVD.
Tabernacles.
My last one and I just
didn't know what to call it.
I had no idea what to call it.
I sat down and I had no fucking answers.
I should've called me.
Why though?
I mean life from Jack and dino.
I like live from the Tabernacle.
Where is it?
It was at the Tabernacle and Atlanta.
It's on Joe rogan.net.
I assume it's from fucking Salt Lake City.
Is the Tabernacle,
the Mormon Tabernacle choir.
Stupid.
See,
I wouldn't call it log chains and water
bottles of water be how are the more
cocktails?
I have more cocktails.
I have that more likely
I am to call Joe Rogan.
Stupid
shit gets crazy fucking two drinks
away from fucking taekwondo.
That guy that,
uh,
did you see that photo that was
on the cover of the New York Post?
The guy got thrown into the,
um,
the train tracks.
Yeah.
When we were like,
this man is about to die and they see
the garlic trying to climb out as a trans
coming.
Did you see that?
I didn't see the unedited.
To me it was more evidence,
like avoid conflict at all costs.
All right.
Everybody that wants a mouth off to
people in public and when to fucking puff
your chest out and flare,
you go stop.
No,
that's why you go on Facebook
and say something off.
Go on youtube and comment
on someone's video.
Tell them the diamond fire.
Oh,
you're a big man behind the keyboard.
Uh,
yeah cause I don't want to
get pushed under a subway.
Stupid.
That's what you're supposed be a big man.
That's called
evolution.
Fuck face.
Okay.
Now man,
when you have a gun,
that's why he got a gun,
because you would have punched the
shit out of me when I'm fucking week.
Really?
It's amazing.
You should be,
you should really be applauding someone's
figured out her not have to do squats
and bison meat for 10 years.
Look at that.
That's it.
Pushed onto a subway track.
This man is about to die.
I fucked up picture.
Sure.
I wanted to say Jake Lamata in all his,
uh,
fog.
Ooh.
Remember when you trained
me to fight Tonya Harding?
Yes.
He actually tried to train.
Yeah,
a little bit.
He laughed hysterically at my complete
absolute ignorance of physical dexterity.
Uh,
she wouldn't sign the boxing
gloves that I fought her with,
cause she said,
well,
people will just put this on Ebay.
People being me.
Wait,
I'm the one asking.
So you're saying people
will put it on Ebay.
So those boxing gloves had been hanging
up in my house forever and Jake Lamata
in all his fog signed them for me.
So fuck you Tonya Harding
not signing my boxing gloves,
but now they're assigned by Jake Lamont.
Now they're worth a hundred times more.
You you're pals with Jake Lamata.
Does he live in Bisbee?
Yeah,
there's no pal.
He doesn't know who I am.
I've said,
you know,
he's coming to my show.
We went to his show.
We played poker at his house in Maya.
He has no idea who I am.
That is that.
Is that gone?
And uh,
if you're on the Stan hope,
celebrity death,
poole.com and you're thinking about Jake
Lamata thinking you're the first person
to think of it.
No,
Bingo already has him and Joey Diaz.
That's supposed to say that.
Why?
I had fucking Ron shock
and I feel bad about it.
Did you want shocks long gone?
Yeah,
he died.
Well,
you win.
But this is what happened
for full disclosure.
I had my list.
We every new years,
me and Joby and Bingo Joby
started this like death pool.
He started doing it for us.
And then it's such a pain in
the ass to keep track of like,
okay,
we have 38 people in our
pool and we have money on it.
But two,
you have 38 people picking 20 celebrities.
How many fucking,
so every day someone dies,
Joby has to go through who had what.
He's had pain in the ass.
So he decided to make this
website that does all that for,
for us.
That's what Stan of
celebrity death pool is.
So,
uh,
New Year's eve is that's when we break
out our picks and we all sit there and
like 10,
how would you find,
who'd you find?
And another girl,
Melissa holding in our town and,
and uh,
we didn't,
we were too drunk to do it.
New Year's Eve.
So New Year's morning I wake
up and Vince fluke is a comic,
emailed me,
Hey,
you know,
Ron shock cancer and we
want to do a benefit.
And so you immediately pull it out like,
well,
we haven't released our picks in,
Oh,
you son of a bitch.
What kind of cancer?
No,
I di,
I did send him some money and I,
I promoted to all of his shit,
but death pool is death pool and
affect the outcome of Ron shocks death.
But I immediately I took,
I took the iron sheik out,
I put it Ron shock and,
and now I'm
nine days away from fucking first place.
Ben Goes in third place out of 30,
unless you get for this,
uh,
was 50 bucks a piece,
I'll get $900 for first shit and the
people are runs it over and people are
like,
we felt we'd been your death pool.
I'm going to set up a fucking open
illegal gambling fucking operate.
No.
If you want to gamble on your own,
you do that,
but you can't be in our death
pool.
Yeah.
How dare you,
how dare you strive and you
make up your own league.
We just do all the fucking book work,
which is why we were going to stop doing
it because it's that much of a pain in
the,
by the way.
How beautiful would it be if this
country was so free that you could have a
death pool on Doug Stan hope.com and
you could take it a little taste.
Oh,
how about,
how about you health billion
dollar everybody and hey,
we need to create jobs.
Well,
all the fucking illegal
gambling is going to fucking UK,
Caribbean,
Coasta Rica.
Yeah.
Those countries are doing fine.
Yeah,
you're fucked.
They're fucking illegal gambling
and they're getting the $12 billion.
You've that gambling is
the one male prostitution.
You have the fucking Jesus
and the fucking drugs and
gambling.
Gambling.
Everyone's doing it every mile.
It's available too.
It's just like drugs.
You can go to the fucking corner store
and you could play scratch tickets.
You can gamble on something.
Yeah.
It's one of those,
it's like swear words that,
okay,
there's kind of a benefit.
There's a benefit in drugs being
illegal because it's a black market.
Fucking,
okay.
I don't have skills.
I can't get a job.
I have three kids.
Oh,
I can sell pot.
Ignore illegal.
Really drives me crazy.
Sports gambling.
The fact that sports
gambling cannot be regulated.
They can't figure out a way to just say,
listen,
if you're an American citizen,
you have to do it in American soil.
Just gamble on,
let's,
let's cut out all the fucking
believes and Costa Rica,
Shit,
let's just look.
You want to keep the economy strong.
What's happening inside America?
Let's have legal gambling
on illegal American servers
that are on American soil.
The taxes go to us.
Slight government gambling,
lotto scratch with a chance to win.
And by the way,
it's makes it more fun.
If you're watching a fucking
football game and you have money on,
it becomes more excited.
I bet.
Only 10 bucks.
I bet on every football game
on Sunday and Monday night,
and now Thursday and occasionally
Saturday and Tuesday if stadium collapses,
it's the only thing that I miss about
working for the UFC is I don't gamble in a
fights.
Really?
No.
Well,
you could call me.
I could,
I have before I hooked up.
Uh,
uh,
Ari Shaffir,
Ari Shaffir was in Vegas and there
was a Glover to sharer was finding.
It was like one of the best
205 pounders in the world.
Nobody's ever heard of him.
First Time in the UFC,
I go bet the House on this motherfucker.
I go back to the house.
I don't tell you that I go,
listen,
this guy is a savage.
I mean he's straight
out of fucking Babylon.
Bet The house.
But everything has got to happen
to Joey Diaz is fucking great.
Youtube picks.
Yeah,
it's busy.
Joey Diaz is too busy.
It's too busy.
The Church of what's happening now as
podcast is almost always in the top 10
iTunes comedy charts now washing it.
That's what we do is can't go me.
You saw what happened when
he went on stage last night.
He can't go anywhere.
He's gone everywhere he goes.
He's selling out every club.
He goes to Santa and the club owners,
these fucking cock suckers,
they don't want to recognize it,
man.
They're trying to low ball
him and give him shitty money.
He's selling out on like
Tuesdays and Thursday nights.
And I tried to bring him,
I get a whole series of
fucking alternative venues
do that.
I'm,
I'm going to produce his,
uh,
he needs to have something in a physical
form out there in a video form and you
know,
and he needs to,
he needs a DV date and so
we're going to produce it.
Yeah.
That's,
come on Christine Levine always like
she played my party and the cops and the
first time in seven years,
we're called to my house and we
have live music in the backyard,
but we live in a small neighborhood where
everyone has to listen to everything
we do,
including uptempo conversations,
people here.
Right.
And she,
she went on stage with an eight minutes.
The police were there
because of the language.
People finally called the cops.
She's fucking brilliant.
Well,
you have a stage in your backyard
that quick.
He says,
yeah,
I get really does.
Yeah.
Well,
no,
I should have fucking tried to
create some semblance of no,
no,
you don't.
You don't have to live in Bisbee.
Okay.
You can go back to Venice.
I had housing with the flag on the hole.
That's ready for you.
Do this doubt each other
day because it's Saturday.
I know there's no traffic idea of traffic.
I W W if I fly into Chicago I will
land at fucking 1130 at night.
So I don't have to,
I hate traffic more than
just makes me crazy.
I don't have that option
because I'm just too busy.
Well you have to live here.
Yeah.
But um,
the one thing that I wouldn't give up
about La is all the people that I know
that live in La.
I mean,
if I had to live like I did
when I lived in Colorado,
I lived away from everybody.
But I saw everybody
when I went on the road.
So it wasn't so
absence makes the heart grow.
When I fucking,
when someone I know comes to Bisbee,
I feel like I've fallen in love again.
Busy fucking rouse and Henry Phillips,
we'll come,
we'll come next time we do a podcast.
Let's do it.
No,
you don't.
Don't come.
And you would hate it.
I want you would fucking
cause you don't like to relax.
I do like the actually wrong.
I do.
Really.
I can imagine you being
so fucking bored there.
No,
no.
Listen,
I like to relax.
I just like to sit
around and Pajama pants.
I don't mind doing that.
What would make you think that?
I don't like to relax.
He was like to do stuff,
but when I'm done I like to relax.
I do like put,
there's no doing stuff to get done from,
but I in my regular life though,
I like that.
Like I,
I went,
he could never do nothing for,
I would challenge you to see
how long you could do nothing.
Like I do nothing.
I can see it in the same pair of Pajama
pants on the same couch watching the
shittiest television shows
and doing absolutely nothing.
Like how many days
I found myself at,
well,
we were on the road once where Brendan
Walsh and I realized we hadn't showered
in seven days.
So we go,
we should really shower and then
we made it to the eighth Oh my God.
How bad is you guys smell?
I would.
You don't smell bad if
you don't exert energy.
That's not true.
You change your socks and
your socks still stink.
Olfactory senses socks cover it up.
No,
they told,
yes,
they do need baby powder.
All all fact.
Use the powder because you sweat because
you're exerting energy by going to the
store.
Maybe
talking to your hotel room.
All factory senses apparently
only detect changes in smell.
That's how people live in shitty
areas like drive through Pennsylvania,
hoarders,
people that live in my
towel around your pillow.
They don't smell it.
People that go to cow towns and you know
like how the fuck do people live here?
The people that live there,
they don't smell it cause your,
your nose detects changes in smell.
It's really weird like that.
Yeah.
That's how homeless people go.
What do you mean or I can't get a ride.
I'm going to stinking up your car.
Yeah.
I can only sit around for a few hours.
I unfortunately have a furnace
that I have to throw wood into.
I got to keep moving.
This is who I am.
You have a furnace inside me,
inside myself.
Oh,
okay.
All right.
Sorry.
Is there a metaphor?
All of a sudden it's a metaphor for
change will come picture Joe Rogan living
off the grid.
I would like to,
I I look,
I tried to do that when
I lived in Colorado.
I pretty much lived off the grid.
You know the House that I was,
I was like eight miles down
a dirt road in the woods,
off the grid,
like Bisbee off the grid where there's
a whole community that's off the grid
solar,
there's be solar.
A lot of it is that they have a whole
community off the grid that they don't
have electric fills.
It's all solar.
Yeah.
No,
I have no bills and
that'll be at my house.
I'm setting that up at
my house in California.
I,
you know why I think were
ridiculous and not do that.
If you have the availability,
like why would you want to be defined?
I don't have the people.
Yeah.
That's one of like the
occupy thing where they go,
no,
we want to work.
I have so many things I want to spend
money on in Bisbee and there's people that
know how to do it and I could stand
on a ladder waving cash and uh,
well Yo,
they've all,
I can think about it and I'm,
maybe we put a thing together to see
how much and then never hear from them
again.
Like I want,
I want a new fucking bathroom.
My bathroom is ugly as shit.
I wouldn't get anybody to work on this.
Be just devoid of contractors.
Unemployment is the fucking major or
disability is the major income there.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's isn't it funny how people
become addicted to like aid?
That's a strange thing with
people like this welfare state.
Well like wait,
before I get fucking Bisbee turned on me,
there's a lot of people that
just work enough to live.
They don't want to work.
Right.
And they don't have big bills.
Almost everyone watches TV on the
Internet on a laptop and don't pay for it.
So yeah,
they'll download shit.
They just don't want to work.
Well,
I understand that.
I'm completely behind it.
Well isn't the idea.
It's,
it's an artist community,
right?
Is it the idea which means how
far it is a fucking redneck.
A real job.
Half artist have rednecks.
Balance doesn't happen.
It's a,
it's the only small town I could
ever live in that I've found.
Have you found anybody that's moved
to that town because they're crazy.
Doug.
Stan hope fans.
One guy.
Do you remember that guy?
Knew it.
One Guy,
but he wasn't,
it wasn't bothersome.
I didn't know.
He said I moved here because you
talked about it on the Internet,
but he lives in old Bisbee.
I'm,
I'm well that's different.
I mean that,
look,
if you told me,
uh,
the one,
the reasons why I moved to boulder
is someone told me about Boulder's,
about how beautiful boulder is,
and then I went down.
I'm like,
Holy Fuck.
They were right.
There's nothing wrong with
accepting correct information.
You're talking about how
great you love Bisbee.
There's no money there.
There's no you can't I,
yeah,
but that resonates with some people.
That's what they're looking for.
They're looking for like
a relaxed sort of asleep.
You can't make a living there.
So you ask,
you want to work in the Deli at Safeway?
Unloading cannot keep fucking anyone at
the Safeway because Colin Evelyn at the
deli neighbor,
Dave's wife.
Oh yeah.
Neighbor Dave's wife.
She's a deli manager and nobody answered.
Be The deli person and safe way
because all the positions pay the same.
And the Deli is where you lose a finger.
It's a hard job.
They're like,
fuck it,
I'll be a bagger.
Ah,
okay.
Well that does make sense.
Yes.
So does that one of my favorite bits on
a turning it before talking referendum
number two,
death squad.
Yes.
Gets safe way to change
their fucking a wage.
All right.
You know some crazy desk on character
moving to fucking Bisbee to be the the,
the Doug just want to tell you,
you know you,
you brought it up on the Joe podcast
and then I knew that I was mad to me the
Deli person at Bisbee in the Safeway,
there was something missing in my life.
I didn't even know what it said to you.
Said that it was like a
light went off in my head.
Man.
I just want to tell you,
I really love you and want to get your
first tattooed on my body somewhere.
Okay?
We've had some,
oh wait,
we had those people show up for football.
They were trying to find my
house cause I put my address.
Okay.
Get a pen.
People two,
one,
two vans.
Street bidding goes over in her eyes.
Bingo.
No,
Yes sir.
You live with a woman,
you know,
take care of,
but I have people send shit to Bingo
because I do this all the time and Bingo.
So retarded.
The packages will show up.
Hang on.
Here you go.
That's,
that's people calling him.
Why don't you just put your phone on off?
Fuck.
Who is this thing called?
Speaker phone.
Are you listening?
Jaylee.
Oh well I'm on the Joe Rogan podcast and
we're just re upping the you versus red
band.
Who's the better fucking tour
manager slash webcast guy?
See My fucking guy is prescient.
That holds you already
bet you got a slave.
All right.
I have a master craftsman call you back.
If I,
if I text Brian,
he calls me back like an hour.
There it goes,
you know,
and so
someone with talent,
I don't have to call my guy,
I think his name,
like beetle juice and he calls into the
show because he's got no talent cause
he's scared.
Brian's out there having threesomes with
porn stars and he comes back and tells
me about it.
Okay,
I'll take my guy over yours.
All right,
I'll take my guy over years.
All Day.
How about that?
Not that there's anything
wrong with your guy.
I'm not saying
I find Red Ben.
Even more adorable than you.
Look.
Thank you.
I don't know what to say about that.
Am I competitive instincts get fueled.
You must not be correct possible.
You must be wrong all along with you.
No matter what.
What were we talking about before Charlie?
Bucket check.
Probably blow jobs and bad teeth.
Oh,
okay.
You're,
you're a,
those people came to your house to watch.
Someone was driving around
trying to find my house.
I know it was during football and they,
they uh,
they went to a local store
in old Bisbee and said,
hey,
do you know where Doug Stanhope lives?
And it's the Sh uh,
wife of the guy that's always at football.
They just happen to go into
that store and she's like,
there's a guy looking around,
right?
So she calls you doing the
hand up to the [inaudible].
I did the imaginary
phone,
hand motion,
add a site.
I go,
yeah,
fuck it.
It's football.
They can,
anyone can come over Durham.
So you let anybody come over your house
for football,
for football.
That makes sense.
If I'm in town for football,
so let's,
let's,
let's it
looking like the Nero scan
and I'm not even tripping.
I'm looking like to Niro again.
Mark Babbitt.
I'm Deniro.
I'm Joe Rogan.
But Hey,
I am wearing last time
when I was tripping,
you fucking look like the de Niro and
which one in Cape fear or in raging bull,
I don't know.
But last night it was seriously
mark Babbitt because of
the shading of your head
made you look like you had
bald guy hair in the back.
I was um,
uh,
thinking about your,
a bad teeth thing.
You know about you.
You have a thing about
bad teeth and the smile.
I just have miserable.
I have to give this one one person props.
This is girl who's a ring
card girl for Bela Tarr.
Look at that.
Oh Wow.
Oh yeah,
exactly.
Like,
look,
come on man.
That doesn't make you want to fuck again.
Look at that.
Look at that picture.
Her name is,
her name is jade Bryce.
But anyway,
she's got like a gap between her teeth,
but she's so hot.
It doesn't,
well that's Bella,
Donna.
No,
no,
no.
Good gap.
Yeah.
But her gap is filled with like shitty
covered dicks that came right out of
butts right in her mouth.
This girl's a little bit
cleaner and it's a little,
little cleaner situation.
Dawna then,
then does jade price girl Bella,
Donna,
we've always had very
different tastes in women.
Well,
was Bella Donna dirty?
She's a little dirty,
right?
Not that it's bad.
Oh,
I like her.
She seems this other girl,
just jade price check is just
simply a girl holds up ring cards.
She's not like getting
like ass to mouth all day.
Different sort of a situation.
What's wrong?
I don't know why you have
to compare that girl.
This girl I'm talking to you about one
girl and you've got to bring up another
girl that you'd go.
I was like,
this is confusing.
I tried to give some girls some props
and she doesn't get fixed her teeth,
but she's got a ridiculous ass.
Look at that ass.
Brian.
Please.
Can I get a witness?
Yeah.
That's a nice ass.
That's about as good as it gets.
No,
I don't like that ass.
You don't like that ass right there.
Shut up.
Fuck up.
God dammit.
That's where babies come from.
That's maybe still come out of the yes.
No,
no,
no.
That's well that fat is there to
protect the cells or something.
Let's see.
Eggs grow.
You must have a big ass like that means
I'm only getting half of mine in it
because the other half of the
gas is going to hold me up.
It's like an Anaconda with a
metal pipe shoved through it.
That's what it's like.
Stuffed the fat and tied off like a ham
with white string.
Okay.
That's what my Cox like.
God dammit.
We're all different.
Doug's Dan hope don't hate
me for actually lucky pussy.
Jesus Christ.
I like pussy.
I've always had a different idea.
Idea
of what fucking beautiful is.
Oh yeah.
Well listen,
it's all subjective and beauty's
in the eye of the beholder.
Yeah,
for real.
I mean there's like a lot of dudes,
there's websites dedicated
to guys who love,
like really overlooked overweight women.
They love like rolls of fat and I think
a lot of that has also has to do with
what you were first introduced
to when you were becoming sexual.
Like if you have a girlfriend,
if you start getting,
not
even talk sexual attractive.
Okay.
I literally attract like
attracts like yours.
Stunning.
There's something about you that I want
to keep looking at as far as porn goes.
Jacking off.
Yes.
That probably ruined a lot of my sex
drive is I was so in a porn than,
and it's never like that.
It's never perfectly cleaned.
Trimmed,
sanitized.
Chlorine with Brian [inaudible]
smokes tear when it smells
wins over your guy once again.
Just one one more time.
God Damn it.
No,
I know what you're talking about.
It's like,
well I had a girl when I first started
dating and I was in high school,
had like very unusual
feat shed weird feet.
She had like,
like,
like kind of like are we talking
jerking off or just what you want?
You're sexually tried to ops
and makes you honey honey.
That girl I think is fucking phenomenally
beautiful because she's engaging,
she's attracting you see or you see like
I see a commercial with a supermodel
and I look at her going,
how boring would she be?
Like she wouldn't want to eat a thing
like the all the things that race through
your head as she would be sold.
No.
How dare you?
Earliest headshot.
That's my,
I was 20 years of garden.
How do you say a link to that
as a Twitter fan of the show?
I get really upset when you're
doing stuff that only you,
us are enjoyable.
Red Band.
We'll put that on his Twitter
red ban and you can see it.
That is my 20 I was 21 years old.
It was an open miker.
That was my headshot.
I don't.
Nice head of hair.
It was really nice.
You were worried about there.
You've got me on fucking Rogaine for,
I should have shaved my
head a long time ago.
It was like what first?
When I first started doing it,
I was like,
it's like so freeing.
It was like a feels good or
scar and not nearly as bad.
We have our friend Billy bad who's like,
he's the to Alaska,
but he is.
He's the fucking,
yeah.
How was he in that way in the world?
He's,
he's you.
He's the U of Alaska.
If I go up there and without the fun,
he's just cool.
Like the coolest,
nicest,
but he did the same thing you did.
But he has this Charlie Brown Frankenstein
scar that goes in a triangle pattern
around us and,
and now he's shaved.
His head is,
he got to the age are like fuck and fuck.
It was the last,
I don't give a fuck left.
I didn't have any,
I don't give a fuck sloughed.
So shaving my head was the last,
I don't give a fuck and what had
happened as soon as I did and I was like,
ah,
that was Jesus and your scar to me.
Cause like you definitely you would
talk about that for a year is about like
your scar.
Like I wish I could shake my head but I
don't want to because the scar must have
been like three or four years and once
he shaved it was like Brody Stevens scar
on his face that he always talks about
it and that I never see Brody Stevens
crazy where you're like,
all right,
I'm crazy.
All right,
now it's out.
Yeah,
it was like fucking,
you know Charlie Sheen going,
yeah,
I fucked hookers.
I'm in court.
Yeah.
I made them dress up like cheerleaders.
Okay.
Once you stopped and I hit,
no one cares.
Yeah.
Once it's out there,
it's out there and until it's out there,
it's always something you
want to fucking hate them.
Baldness is like considered a disease
on some levels where like that kids with
cancer,
I'm going to shave her
head to give them a hair.
Like,
wait,
I don't have fucking hair mine,
so I'm supposed to be as
embarrassed as a child.
Like I'm some kind of Google to a child.
That's funny.
I know.
Some health care we'll
cover baldness like what?
I'm supposed to feel bad.
I don't give up.
I know,
right.
It's a weird thing.
It's a,
it's a,
well,
you know what a part of it is,
it's like a lack of control thing.
Have you don't have control over something
like eyebrows are important to people
who know why they're important to people.
If they fell off you'd be like,
where's my fucking eyebrows?
But if you shave my eyebrows,
my life wouldn't change at all except
for the fact that people would realize I
don't have eyebrows anymore,
but they have no fucking purpose and
they wouldn't want to talk about it.
That's why the inch will be the men
like a Mexican gang banger check.
The Internet will change how we
feel about honesty across the board.
I think it already has,
isn't it?
Well,
to the point where it now you will
be open about things because you know
someone's going to say it about
you on Facebook beyond your,
oh,
the guy next to me has the
fucking weirdest died prowess
in the cubicle next to
it and he's going to be,
I'm going to hit on the chicken,
the cubicle next to me.
Oh wait,
she's talking about me.
I'm the only one with no eyebrows.
People will be open about stuff.
That whole level of politeness that
has nothing to do with civility.
It's not being rude.
Oh,
you,
oh,
you have a flipper arm.
What's that like?
Right?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's just absent actually
asking a question.
Of course you're different.
People are going to be intrigued.
Like,
did you remember that?
I don't know if she paid attention to all,
but the Olympics,
that guy that was running
who I'd fake legs.
Yeah.
It was really running really fast.
So like these prosthetic,
sorry.
Yeah,
but steroids or illegal,
right?
Bionic man,
fine.
Well,
we had this guy on the podcast,
Daniel Wilson,
he's a robotics experts.
He's written some books and
robotics and he was talking once,
he goes,
how long before the first guy cuts his
legs off and puts bionic legs on him.
And what he said in my
whole body is swelling.
No,
that's not what I thought of.
I thought of the actual guy lying
there with a tube down his throat,
gene of shutting them off while
they're sawing is fucking legs off.
And I was terrified.
I literally like cuddled up
with myself like thinking about,
I know someone one day is going to cut
off their perfectly good legs for some
thug Mike Lang or even if
it's not to win a medal,
it's just to have bionic legs.
Oh Two oh recognition and what?
We're going to be his mother
front of its recognition.
Just the ability.
How about if somebody,
okay,
listen how fast you need to run
it in a world full of cars living.
Let me ask you this.
If they came out with fucking legs
and these are these bionic legs,
allowed you to jump over buildings,
literally allowed you to go incredible
hulk style and just leap like a fucking
airplane.
Fly through space.
Why wouldn't you want to do that?
But you would have to sit there while
they saw your hip off and try to cut your
bleeding off at the fucking
arteries around your legs.
The femoral artery that if
they cut that with a knife,
it's sprays out and you bleed out.
Understand what are the worst ways
to die is getting shot in the thigh.
You get shot in the thigh,
it blows out your artery,
your debt.
It's just,
you're just like
got from the Redskins.
The Redskins.
Someone just died getting shot.
Fucking thigh.
Yeah,
getting shot in the thigh.
Car Accident.
I have to back off like we're saying
sandy hook cause it wasn't overly
publicized.
Ha.
Yeah.
If it was overly publicized,
we apologized and somebody has
something they put on Twitter.
That was so fucking poignant when
that sandy hook thing was going on.
They said 20 kids on a 20 kids die in
Connecticut and it is a national outrage.
150,000 die from starvation.
No
die from drone strikes
and no one and Brca one.
I retweeted.
Yeah,
well then I bet there was a lot of those.
I mean it wasn't one person who made that
obvious conclusion of the PA cracy of
the way we look at things.
We have a really crazy way of
looking at things that we don't look,
there's a lot of innocent
children that have died.
Let me ask you this,
as a father now,
which I tried to avoid that thought,
not nearly as much as the idea
that Joey Diaz is a father,
which I actually did the calculations of
today out front waiting for you to show
up.
It's like,
okay,
got Joey Diaz and the death pool,
but he's about to be a father that's
going to give them more reason to live,
and I'm,
I'm like,
uh,
I'm like a prognosticator
at the horse track.
Why is it he's a,
he's,
he's good on a wet track,
but that's funny.
But you as a father,
do you do,
did you feel anything about Sandy Hook?
Like
I felt two things.
One thing I felt is for the actual
kid who did that emotionally,
yes.
I'm talking emotional.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I felt,
I felt for two for,
for in two situations.
One,
I felt for the actual child that became
that fucking monster that's gunning
children
and you know,
his mother and whoever else
he killed his teachers.
I felt for that guy because you don't
get to the point where you're showing up
at a school and just shooting children
unless you're in horrific pain.
I don't know what was going
on with him psychologically,
and there's a lot of people that they
really shy away from having any empathy
towards someone who does horrific things,
but everyone who does horrific things
does horrific things because they're in
pain.
There's no other way to do it.
There's no real,
there's no other reason to lash out.
There's no way that guy did that for
the reason I would want to kill a lot of
people.
Mine is completely out of logical.
Yeah.
Sheer focused anger.
He,
you don't shoot a bunch of children.
Real eugenics,
like the idea of Eugenics,
like just weeding out all the
people that want to kill people,
weeding out all the people who are
sociopaths weeding all the people who are
psychopaths,
which is what you do in any
other natural like ecosystem,
whether it's with animals.
If you have a bunch of animals and you
have some goats running and one goat
keeps killing the baby goats,
you like,
you shoot that goat and then you
don't have that problem anymore.
But with human beings,
it's like this ethical consideration of
who this person is and makes no sense.
It does make no sense.
It's there.
There,
there does need to be some sort of a
pragmatic like a like removing people like
that from,
from the population but also,
but here's realize what,
what takes a baby when you have children.
One of the things about having children
that changed me is just the realization
ducks down on made me smoke
a cigarette last night.
Oh that's right.
I took two hits off that.
He choked like I did on his weed.
So gross.
But it did give me,
I was totally head Russian,
but having a child when,
when when you have a baby,
one of the things you realize is the
massive responsibility that you have
because this is a bundle of potential
that this child like could turn out
completely fucked up or completely
beautiful and amazing and I don't mean
beautiful looking.
I mean like the way they behave,
the way they communicate with people,
that people are going to be enriched and,
and like their life is going to be better
because they come in contact with the
parents of this sandy hook shooter have
the same expectations of that child.
Of course they did.
But that's the,
that's the main Hubris of parents
thinking that because your bright,
you can,
you have control over your child.
You can have the best intentions.
This is what Todd,
I did Todd glasses,
podcasts and this whole conversation
spiraled out of control because he was
miss.
Uh,
he wasn't understanding what I'm saying
because you're a parent doesn't mean
that you have any control over
what your child's going to be calm.
Well that's a,
it's,
I don't think it's an either or situation
and I think that's the real problem is
that just because some people have
this idea that you have this bundle of
potential,
this
child that's essentially a blank slate
in front of you and you would like them
to be a productive citizen.
That doesn't mean that the,
the people who create a sandy hook
person have those same intentions in mind
because a lot of people have babies and
they just have a fucking baby and they
just live and they fuck the kid up with
whatever they're fucked up with and they
don't have a lot of objectivity and they
don't have a lot of self awareness and
they don't have a lot of understanding
of the greater picture of what it is to
take a,
essentially a bundle of
potential and in neurons,
which is a baby and,
and turn it into a full
functioning human being.
It's a massive responsibility.
And people don't look at it like
the massive responsibility that is.
But what you're saying is you still think
you have control if you do not know.
I do not.
Cause I know that first of all,
as wall bit,
I fucking love from it.
He had a bit about,
uh,
kids always rebelled
against their parents.
So I'm going to be the
worst parent in the world.
I'm going to be the biggest douche.
I'm going to have Phil Collins,
no jacket required album
framed on the mantle piece.
They did.
So my kids are cool.
They don't always rebel.
I know people,
it made me think of that bit.
I think human beings rebel against
someone who tells him what to do.
And the only time kids
tell you what to do where,
or rather a person tells a kid what to do,
where it makes sense is where the,
the kid is,
uh,
explained is explained to them in a way
that alleviates all of their concerns,
that you're trying to control
them all of their concerns,
that you're insensitive to their,
their own individual lights.
You now not if they're like you,
if they're a bundle,
I'm saying if they are like you,
then you can explain this.
But if they reject that and they
have [inaudible] don't understand,
they don't reject that from the start.
Because children have,
they don't really have a set of morals
and you can explain to them as time goes
on what is wrong or right
about certain situations.
They will absorb a certain amount of
it and you can continue to provide good
examples there.
The real issue and is that raising a
kid is not as simple as people like to
pretend it is.
It's a massive amount of work.
Fuck you Joe,
or inside,
just wanted to throw in some kind of cool.
It's just something,
something to keep the listener engaged.
Oh,
this is going somewhere.
Fuck you.
It's just the look.
It's what what a kid is is like,
it's like having a phd thesis and you're,
you're giving it to any retard and say,
hey,
fill this out.
Figure it out,
and they don't.
You don't tell him what to do.
Like fill this out.
Some people are just naturally going
to write some incredible thesis.
You're going to have some new points that
haven't been considered by science and
send.
Some kids are going to shoot up sandy
and some people are going to wipe their
ass with it and they're going to like
put sand in it and they're going to throw
it in the ocean.
It's like Eh,
there the amount of room for
error and the amount of possibility and
raising a child is so monumental that
most people are going to get it wrong.
Just like most people going to get wrong.
Their own objective
perceptions of themselves,
how few,
how many people were really see themselves
the way the other people around them.
So I feel like the only listeners now
are the same people who listened to art
about your Ra.
I'm telling right now your work
because people that have kids,
Doug,
Stan hope.
I just feel like right now we've
delved into fucking up all night.
No,
we have it because what we're talking
about some really important shit when
we're talking about is what,
that's why people turn to and out.
But it's fascinating.
What is it that makes a person a psycho?
What does it makes a person awesome.
What do you mean?
Look,
you and I both had very
different childhoods,
but we essentially found our own
path instead of being guided.
That's what I was going to say is,
uh,
I,
I'm basing a lot of this on intervention
is one of our favorite shows and
hoarders does the same thing to an extent
where they start out with the problem
and then they coast into a montage of
their childhood and they try to at least,
if not pinpoint a allude to,
well then their parents get divorced and
she missed her father or then she was
tired of buying uncle became comforting.
Fuck,
but they try to find something in the
childhood that's responsible with no
science whatsoever that is responsible
for why now they're fucking shitting in a
dumpster and a fucking crime.
When you say science,
that's really important
because it's purely anecdotal
evidence you would have to
take to people,
make them live fucking a strong,
it is.
It absolutely is.
That's a very good point.
The way you just said that I had to be
to really would love to fucking meet
doctor drew a face to face.
I would love to set that up because that
was one of my favorite bits about that
bit,
that uh,
turning the gun on himself as well.
It's like you fucking nailed it.
Like what is your cure?
And it's God,
it's a higher power mean.
That's all they saw.
Biggest breach of separation of church
and state is where people get a Dui and
they're forced to go to Aa for two or
six weeks where they have to pretend to
believe in God.
You mother fuckers,
it's absolutely again in raging,
yes and not on the language.
Fuck is a bad word level,
but still,
but here's the thing is they
always try to blame the Po.
I my,
my parents were great.
I'm a fuck up.
Hold up.
Stop,
stop it.
Stop it.
You're not a fuck up.
But
in the eyes of all of
those types of shows,
I would be seen as some,
no,
no.
You won't.
You're going to die if
they're misinformed.
You know what that's like.
The eyes of that show is like if someone
gets brought in and the person happens
to be a person who has asthma and you,
you don't have a doctor present to say,
well what causes asthma?
Okay.
If you were on a show
and they were saying,
well there's something
wrong with his Doug,
Stan Hope,
Doug Sahm have likes to drink,
he drinks almost every day.
I would have to step
in because I was like,
well you understand comics.
He,
I'm an expert on comments.
This is a comic and this is how it works.
And you don't get comics like that unless
you get all the other shit as well.
Okay.
Are we cool?
All right,
good.
Now go back to judging fucking mailroom
workers and fucking insurance salesmen
because when it comes to comics,
that's where I'm an expert.
So you're not a fuck up.
You're not a fuck up cause you put out
a good solid hour every year and a half
and there's only one
way to fucking do that.
Okay?
It's to do a Doug Stan hope style.
The way you're doing it is the
exact correct way to do it.
And if you took those
assholes and you said,
hey,
listen,
I want to take,
we take time away from working
at La Fitness and being that the,
the guy who recruits new
people to be personal trainers.
And what I want you to do,
I just want to push you to get her.
I want you to put together an hour
of solid subversive standup material.
We really analyze to society's woes and
a break it down a in a way that's not
just going to be pulling it,
but it's also going to elicit a reaction
out of people is going to make them
laugh,
belly laugh.
How will I want you to take points
to the point where you think it's
uncomfortable and socially unacceptable
and go about a hundred yards past that
and do some horrible place
where you long for the,
the moment where you thought that
he was out of line in the beginning,
which was four minutes ago,
that guy can't do that.
So that guy would be a fuck
up if he tried to do your job.
Oh,
you,
uh,
you turn the forklift in the
wrong direction and hit some cans.
You need to be on intervention.
Yeah,
we got you miss three tags,
like standing up in that hour.
We got seven minutes ago before
recording turns into a pumpkin.
We hit the four hour,
the three hour mark.
Right.
You have the shit,
man.
I wish you lived here,
but I don't because every
time you come back here,
it's like Christmas.
Exactly.
When someone shows up in Bisbee,
I hugged them.
I listen to this show that we did.
Like I said,
Bingo.
Said the other day,
I,
I'm ready to get out of it.
We were off work for two
weeks and she's like,
I'm ready to get out of town.
Let's go on the road.
I go,
we're going to be on the road for fucking
one night for the Rogan thing of we're
going to be,
I can't wait to get back home right now.
You can't wait already.
I'm always fucking greener pastures,
man.
Everything I'm not in is better with that.
So it makes you a comic man.
People don't understand.
They don't understand that.
We all have our own place in
this crazy spectrum of life.
Yeah.
Your,
your,
your place.
Let me plug Superbowl in.
Bisbee you have to fucking
get your own place.
I already have fucking,
the houses are full,
but you just can't stay
at the shady Dell will.
You're gonna first of all,
let's just let people come to
your house and watch the game.
Yes.
Okay.
Listen,
we're putting this on the Internet.
1 million people will listen
to this coming so far away.
I can't get you to come to my house.
I said crazy per se.
Can't.
That's incorrect.
The correct.
The correct is haven't gotten me.
I will.
The point is I live so far away.
Crazy people have to be really fucking
crazy.
The ones you've got to worry about
and there comes a point is no,
we have a show.
Listen to this lineup coming on.
Don't fucking Andy Andrist.
Christine Levine,
Sean rouse,
j t hab are set.
Fucking someone I'm forgetting and
I'm hosting is Friday junior stopcock.
Oh,
beautiful.
How many followers does he have?
Let's check right now.
So when you said that I
was just about the check.
Hold on one second.
Go with all of the Biz.
Be Roy Bisbee Royale.
Fucking best bar in Bisbee.
Brand new where his junior
stock or what the fuck?
I just followed them at junior stop.
Go.
Okay,
hold on.
So that's Friday night.
The show is that the Bisbee Royale,
Friday night,
fucking six of my favorite
fucking comics in the world.
1,350 we'd,
we really got them over a hundred
people listen to this shit later.
You weak ass pitches,
but there's more than know though.
There's thousands of them
that are listening to right
now who listens to fucking
podcast live this shit in the car.
The hardcore freaks.
Alright,
the hardcore,
well,
we have 53 junior stopped the really
upset by your video called all in fucking
Iceland or New Zealand and they're not
going to see junior stop cut anyway or
Alaska.
They will.
They're traveling,
they're gonna come to your house,
you know,
fuck.
If you want to come to Doug,
Stan hope's house for Superbowl,
the address is 12 van Dyke Street.
Like Dick Van Dyke Bisbee a z eight five,
six Oh three,
and put it in your knees,
but you're not staying there.
Take your,
come from the party.
Take your meds.
If you're coming,
let me know.
Cause my brother flies out from Rhode
Island of do barbecue for people.
He expects 80 people.
If we're going to have fucking 150 yeah,
let them know.
Or you don't eat if your hands are sweaty.
White Mom.
Well here's the deal.
Friday night is the comedy show.
That's fuck.
That's a strong fucking light up.
That's a strong line.
Saturday will be a like
local musicians at my house.
Uh,
and Sunday is the warming.
Friday night as well.
I'm hosting,
do not going to do a
long sell fucking host.
You don't son of a bitch.
You don't sh I'll,
I'll y'all shit where you eat or exactly.
That's nonsense.
You need to do a God damn set.
Dot.
Doing done it twice.
It uh,
yeah.
When you have to see a town of 6,000
people and someone doesn't look at you in
the eye,
they look at you and then look down.
Just looking down,
but in your head you're going,
they saw my show and they hate me.
I'm standing help.
You have a mission.
A mission is convert that
town to the cult of stats.
Why you don't work?
Cruise ships is Dan hope.
Sausage factory.
What does it the sausage crew.
We're fucking sausage
army is that squad now.
We're just a branch.
It's a branch of desk walk.
We've been overtaken by
desk auto desk squad.
When's ladies and gentlemen,
Doug Stan hope experience can
be found@dougstanhope.com.
You can follow Doug on Twitter.
Doug's Stan hope at Doug's.
Dan Hope on Twitter.
Thank you.
Thank you Doug.
Stanhope.
Thanks to audible.com
for being there for us.
You dirty fucks.
Shaylee fucking crushes red band.
I don't know what you're saying.
That's a fucking,
that's the junior del Santos.
Fucking Cain Velasquez.
Fine Velasquez next weekend.
You dirty bitches.
Listen,
I'd be watching.
It's over from Florida while I'm fighting.
Of course.
Are you going to be in Florida?
Oh,
your court hearing?
That's right.
You can get free.
Come to Vegas.
I'll hook you up.
Um,
thanks to a look thanks to
everybody that came last night.
And,
uh,
I think I speak Kaylee's
coming to the Superbowl.
Are you coming to the Superbowl last year?
We had a list last night for real.
Was like probably like the greatest
night of our continuity going to Vegas.
We're going to do it again.
We're going to do it again
in bigger places and,
and more.
Put it,
we'll do it again in Vienna,
in Vegas.
We'll do it again in la.
We'll do it again as
many places as we can.
They will.
Last night.
It was amazing.
Uh,
I don't know what to say other than the
shit that I say over and over again.
I just couldn't be happier.
I don't,
I don't know how it all happened,
but I'm happy as fuck.
Um,
thanks to audible.com to go to audible.com
forward slash Joe get 33 days and one
free audio book.
It is a great service and they are
a great supporter of the podcast.
Go to [inaudible] dot com it's o,
n,
n.
I t.
Use the code name,
Rogan,
and you could save yourself 10%
off any and all supplements.
And one of the things that I always like
to stress about on it is that on it has
a 100% money back guarantee on all
supplements for the first 90 days.
We running out of time.
Yeah,
we had like a second son.
Bingo.
Took all the brain fuck faces.
I love the shit out here.